[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
again
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
welcome everybody
let's give everyone a moment to
get back in the audience and
all right
great
uh welcome to Tesla AI day 2022.
all right
[Applause]
we've got some really exciting things to
show you
um I think you'll be pretty impressed uh
I do want to set some expectations with
respect to uh our Optimus robot
um as as you know last year it was just
a person in a robot suit uh
but uh We've not we've come a long way
and it's I think you know compared to
that it's going to be very impressive
uh and um
we're going to talk about uh the
advancements in AI for full self-driving
as well as how they apply to more
generally to real world AI problems like
a humanoid robot and and even going
beyond that
um I think there's some potential that
what we're doing here at Tesla could
make a meaningful contribution to AGI
um
and um and I think actually tells us a
good entity to do it from a governance
standpoint because we're a publicly
traded company we have one class of of
stock and that means that the public
controls Tesla and I think that's
actually a good thing
um so if I go crazy you can fire me this
is important
maybe I'm not crazy I don't know
um so uh
yeah so we're going to talk a lot about
our progress in AI autopilot as well as
the progress uh in uh with with dojo
and then we're going to bring the team
out and do a long q a so you can ask
tough questions
um whatever you'd like existential
questions technical questions if it
would want to have as much time for Q a
as possible so let's see with that
you guess what daily
hey guys I'm Milan I work on autopilot
and it is rubber
I'm Lizzy
a mechanical engineer on the project as
well
okay
um so should we should we bring up the
vot before we
forward first time we try this robot
without any backup support cranes
mechanical mechanisms no cables nothing
yeah I want to join with you guys
tonight but it was the first time let's
see you ready let's go
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
self-driving computer that runs in your
Tesla cars by the way
[Music]
this is the it's literally the first
time the robot has operated without a
tether was on stage tonight
[Music]
[Music]
that's it so um so the robot can
actually do a lot more than we just
showed you we just didn't want it to
fall on its face uh so we'll we'll show
you some videos now of the robot doing a
bunch of other things
um
yeah which are less risky
um yeah
we should close the screen guys
[Music]
yeah we wanted to show a little bit more
what we've done over the past few months
with apart and just walking around and
dancing on stage ah
just humble beginnings but you can see
the autopilot neural networks running as
is just retrained for the bud uh
directly on that on that new platform
that's my watering can yeah when you see
a rendered view that's that's the robot
what's the that's the world the robot
sees so it's it's very clearly
identifying objects like this is the
object it should pick up picking it up
um
yeah
we use the same process as we did for
autopilot to collect data in train your
networks that we then Deploy on the
robot that's an example that illustrates
the upper body a little bit more
something that we'll like try to nail
down in a few months over the next few
months I would say to perfection
this is really an actual station in the
Fremont Factory as well that it's
working at
yep so
[Applause]
and that's not the only thing we have to
show today right yeah absolutely so
um that what you saw was what we call
Bumble C that's our uh uh sort of rough
development robot uh using
semi-off-the-shelf actuators
um but we actually uh have it's gone a
step further than that already the
team's done an incredible job and we
actually have an optimist bot with a
fully Tesla designed at both actuators
um battery pack uh control system
everything
um it it wasn't quite ready to walk uh
but I think it will walk in a few weeks
but we wanted to show you the robot uh
the the something that's actually fairly
close to what will go into production
and
um and show you all the things it can do
so let's bring it out
do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
laughs
[Music]
foreign
that we expect to have in Optimus
production unit one which is the ability
to move all the fingers independently
move the uh to have the thumb have two
degrees of freedom so it has opposable
thumbs and both left and right hand so
it's able to operate tools and do useful
things our goal is to make a a useful
humanoid robot as quickly as possible
and we've also designed it using the
same discipline that we use in designing
the car which is to say to design it for
manufacturing such that it's possible to
make the robot at in high volume at low
cost with high reliability
so that's incredibly important I mean
you've all seen very impressive humanoid
robot demonstrations
um and that that's great but what are
they missing they're missing a brain
they don't have the the intelligence to
navigate the world uh by themselves and
they're they're also very expensive
um and made in low volume whereas uh
this this is the optimistic society and
extremely capable robot but made in very
high volume probably ultimately millions
of units
um and it is expected to cost much less
than a car
I would say probably less than twenty
thousand dollars would be my guess
[Applause]
the the potential for optimistic is I
think appreciated by very effective
people hey
as usual Tesla demos are coming in hot
so okay that's good that's good
um yeah
um the teams put on put in and the team
has put in an incredible amount of work
uh it's uh working days you know seven
days a week running the 3am oil to to
get to the demonstration today I'm super
proud of what they've done is they've
really done done a great job I just like
to give a hand to the whole option of
this team
[Applause]
so you know that now there's still a lot
of work to be done to refine Optimus and
improve it obviously this is just
Optimus version one
and that's really why we're holding this
event which is to convince some of the
most talented people in the world like
you guys
um to join Tesla and help make it a
reality and bring it to fruition at
scale such that it can help millions of
people
um and the the and the potential it
likes it is is really boggles the mind
because you have to say like what what
is an economy an economy is uh sort of
productive entities times the
productivity uh Capital times output
productivity per capita at the point in
which there is not a limitation on
capita
the it's not clear what an economy even
means at that point an economy becomes
quasially infinite
um so
what what you know taken to fruition in
the hopefully benign scenario
um the this means uh a future of
abundance a future where
um there is no poverty where people you
can have whatever you want in terms of
products and services
um
it really is a a fundamental
transformation of civilization as we
know it
um
obviously we want to make sure that
transformation is a positive one and um
safe
and but that's also why I think
Tesla as an entity doing this being a
single class of stock publicly traded
owned by the public
is very important
and should not be overlooked I think
this is essential because then if the
public doesn't like what Tesla's doing
the public can buy shares in Tesla and
vote differently
this is a big deal
um
like it's very important that that I
can't just do what I want you know
sometimes people think that not but it's
not true
um
so
um
you know that's it's very important that
the the
corporate entity that has that that
makes this happen is something that the
public can properly influence
um and so I think the Tesla structure is
is ideal for that
um
and like I said that you know
self-driving cars will certainly have a
tremendous impact on the world
um I think they will improve the
productivity of Transport by at least
a half order of magnitude perhaps an
order of magnitude perhaps more
um
optimists I think
has
maybe a two order of magnitude uh
potential Improvement
in uh economic output
like like it's not clear it's not clear
what the limit actually even is
um
so
but we need to do this in the right way
we need to do it carefully and safely
and ensure that the outcome is one that
is beneficial to
civilization and and one that Humanity
once
I can't this is also it's extremely
important obviously
so
um
and I hope you will consider uh joining
Tesla to achieve those goals
um it Tesla we really care about doing
the right thing here always aspire to do
the right thing and and really not
pay the road to hell with good
intentions and I think the road to hell
is mostly paved with bad intentions but
every now and again there's a good
intention in there so we want to do it
do the right thing um so you know
consider joining us and helping make it
happen
um with that let's let's uh move on to
the next phase right on thank you Elon
all right so you've seen a couple robots
today let's do a quick timeline recap so
last year we unveiled the Tesla bot
concept but a concept doesn't get us
very far we knew we needed a real
development and integration platform to
get real-life learnings as quickly as
possible so that robot that came out and
did the little routine for you guys we
had that within six months built working
on software integration Hardware
upgrades over the months since then but
in parallel we've also been designing
the Next Generation this one over here
so this guy is rooted in the the
foundation of sort of the vehicle design
process you know we're leveraging all of
those learnings that we already have
obviously there's a lot that's changed
since last year but there's a few things
that are still the same you'll notice we
still have this really detailed focus on
the true human form we think that
matters for a few reasons but it's fun
we spend a lot of time thinking about
how amazing the human body is we have
this incredible range of motion
typically really amazing strength a fun
exercise is if you put your fingertip on
the chair in front of you you'll notice
that there's a huge range of motion that
you have in your shoulder and your elbow
for example without moving your
fingertip you can move those joints all
over the place
um but the robot you know its main
function is to do real useful work and
it maybe doesn't necessarily need all of
those degrees of freedom right away so
we've stripped it down to a minimum sort
of 28 fundamental degrees of freedom and
then of course our hands in addition to
that
humans are also pretty efficient at some
things and not so efficient in other
times so for example we can eat a small
amount of food to sustain ourselves for
several hours that's great uh but when
we're just kind of sitting around no
offense but we're kind of inefficient
we're just sort of burning energy
so on the robot platform what we're
going to do is we're going to minimize
that idle power consumption drop it as
low as possible and that way we can just
flip a switch and immediately the robot
turns into something that does useful
work
so let's talk about this latest
generation in some detail shall we
so on the screen here you'll see in
Orange are actuators which we'll get to
in a little bit and in blue our
electrical system
so now that we have our sort of
human-based research and we have our
first development platform we have both
research and execution to draw from for
this design
again we're using that vehicle design
foundation so we're taking it from
concept through design and Analysis and
then build and validation
along the way we're going to optimize
for things like cost and efficiency
because those are critical metrics to
take this product to scale eventually
how are we going to do that well we're
going to reduce our part count and our
power consumption of every element
possible we're going to do things like
reduce the sensing and the wiring at our
extremities you can imagine a lot of
mass in your hands and feet is going to
be quite difficult and power consumptive
to move around
and we're going to centralize both our
power distribution and our compute to
the physical center of the platform
so in the middle of our torso actually
it is the Torso we have our battery pack
this is sized at 2.3 kilowatt hours
which is perfect for about a full day's
worth of work
what's really unique about this battery
pack is it has all of the battery
Electronics integrated into a single PCB
within the pack so that means everything
from sensing to fusing charge management
and power distribution is all on one all
in one place
we're also leveraging both our Vehicle
Products and our Energy Products to roll
all of those key features into this
battery so that's streamlined
manufacturing really efficient and
simple cooling methods battery
management and also safety
and of course we can leverage Tesla's
existing infrastructure and supply chain
to make it
so going on to sort of our brain it's
not in the head but it's pretty close
also in our torso we have our Central
Computer so as you know Tesla already
ships full self-driving computers in
every vehicle we produce we want to
leverage both the autopilot hardware and
the software for the humanoid platform
but because it's different in
requirements and in form factor we're
going to change a few things first
so we still are gonna it's gonna do
everything that a human brain does
processing Vision data making Split
Second decisions based on multiple
sensory inputs and also Communications
so to support Communications it's
equipped with wireless connectivity as
well as audio support
and then it also has Hardware level
security features which are important to
protect both the robot and the people
around the robot
so now that we have our sort of core
we're going to need some limbs on this
guy and we'd love to show you a little
bit about our actuators and our fully
functional hands as well but before we
do that I'd like to introduce Malcolm
who's going to speak a little bit about
our structural foundation for the robot
[Applause]
thank you
Tesla have the capability to finalize
highly complex systems it does get much
more complex than a crash you can see
here a simulated crash on model 3
superimposed on top of the actual
physical crash
it's actually incredible how um how
accurate it is just to give you an idea
of the complexity of this model
it includes every knot Bolton washer
every spot Weld and it has 35 million
degrees of freedom it's quite amazing
and it's true to say that if we didn't
have models like this we wouldn't be
able to make the safest cars in the
world
so can we utilize our capabilities and
our methods from the automotive side to
influence a robot
well we can make a model and since we
had crash software we used the same
software here we can make it fall down
the purpose of this is to make sure that
if it falls down ideally it doesn't but
it's superficial damage
we don't want to for example break its
gearbox at its arms that's equivalent of
a dislocated shoulder of a robot
difficult and expensive to fix
so we wanted to dust itself off get on
with a job that's been given
if we could also take the same model and
we can drive the actuators using the
input from a previously solved model
bringing it to life
so this is producing the Motions for the
tasks we want the robot to do these
tasks are picking up boxes turning
squatting walking upstairs whatever the
set of tasks are we can play to the
model this is showing just simple
walking we can create the stresses in
all the components that helps us to
optimize the components
these are not dancing robots these are
actually the modal Behavior the first
five modes of the robot and typically
when people make robots they make sure
the first mode is up around the top
single figures up towards 10 Hertz
who is it do this is to make the
controls of walking easier it's very
difficult to walk if you can't guarantee
where your foot wobbling around
that's okay to make one robot we want to
make thousands maybe Millions
we haven't got the luxury of making them
from carbon fiber titanium we want to
make them on plastic things are not
quite so stiff
so we can't have these high targets I'll
call them dumb targets
we've got to make them work at lower
targets so is that is that going to work
well if you think about it sorry about
this but we're just bags of soggy jelly
and Bones thrown in
we're not high frequency if I stand on
my leg I don't vibrate at 10 Hertz
we people operate at low frequency so we
know the robot actually can it just
makes controls harder so we take the
information from this the modal data and
the stiffness and feed that into the
control system that allows it to walk
just changing tax slightly looking at
the knee
we could take some inspiration from
biology and we can look to see what the
mechanical advantages of the knee is it
turns out it actually represents quite
similar to the four bar link and that's
quite non-linear
that's not surprising really because if
you think when you bend your leg down
the torque on your knee is much more
when it's bent than it is when it's
straight
so you'd expect a non-linear function
and in fact the biology is non-linear
this matches it quite accurately
so that's the representation the four by
link is obviously not physically four
bar link as I said the characteristics
are similar but me betting down that's
not very scientific let's be a bit more
scientific we've played all the tasks
through the through this graph but this
is showing pickets of walking squatting
the tasks I said we did on the stress
and that's the uh the talk a scene at
the knee against the knee bend on the
horizontal axis this is showing the
requirement for the knee to do all these
tasks and then put a curve through it
surfing over the top of the Peaks and
that's saying this is what's required to
make the robot do these tasks
so if we look at the four bar link
that's actually the green curve and it's
saying that the non-linearity of the
four by link is actually linearized the
characteristic of the force what that
really says is that's lowered the force
that's what makes the actuator have the
lowest possible Force which is the most
efficient we want to burn energy up
slowly
what's the blue curve well the blue
curve is actually if we didn't have a
four bar link we just had an arm
sticking out of my leg here with a with
an actuator on it a simple two bar link
that's the best you could do with a
simple two bar link and it shows that
that would create much more force in the
actuator which would not be efficient
so what's that look like in practice
well
as you'll see but it's very tightly
packaged in the knee you'll see a good
transparent in a second you'll see the
full bar link there it's operating on
the actuator this is determined the
force and the displacements on the
actuator
and now pass you over to concertina to
tell you a lot more detail about how
these actuators are made and designed
optimized thank you
thank you Michael
[Applause]
so I am I would like to talk to you
about
um the design process and the actuator
portfolio
uh in our robot
so there are many similarities between a
car and the robot when it comes to
powertrain design
the the most important thing that
matters here is energy mass and cost
we are carrying over most of our
designing experience from the car to the
robot
so in the particular case you see a car
with two drive units and the drive units
are used in order to accelerate the car
0 to 60 miles per hour time or drive a
cities Drive site while the robot that
has 28 actuators and
it's not obvious what are the tasks at
the actuator level so we have tasks that
are higher level like walking or
climbing stairs or carrying a heavy
object which need to be translated into
joint into joint specs therefore we use
our model
that generates the torque speed
trajectories for our joints which
subsequently is going to be fed in our
optimization model and to run through
the optimization process
this is one of the scenarios that the
robot is capable of doing which is
turning and walking
so when we have this torque speed
trajectory we laid over an efficiency
map of an actuator and we are able along
the trajectory to generate the power
consumption and the energy accumulative
energy for the task versus time
so this allows us to define the system
cost for the particular actuator and put
a simple Point into the cloud then we do
this for hundreds of thousands of
actuators by solving in our cluster and
the red line denotes the Pareto front
which is the preferred area where we
will look for optimal so the X denotes
the preferred actuator design we have
picked for this particular joint so now
we need to do this for every joint we
have 28 joints to optimize and we parse
our cloud
we parse our Cloud again for every joint
spec and the red axis this time denotes
the bespoke actuator designs for every
joint the problem here is that we have
too many unique actuator designs and
even if we take advantage of the
Symmetry still there are too many in
order to make something Mass
manufacturable we need to be able to
reduce the amount of unique actuator
designs therefore we run something
called commonality study which we parse
our Cloud again looking this time for
actuators that simultaneously Meet The
Joint performance requirements for more
than one joint at the same time so the
resulting portfolio is six actuators and
they show in a color map the middle
figure
um
and the actuators can be also viewed in
this slide we have three rotary and
three linear actuators all of which have
a great
output force or Torque per Mass
the rotary actuator in particular has a
mechanical clutch integrated
on the high speed side angular contact
ball bearing and on the high speed side
and on the low speed side a cross roller
bearing and the gear train is a strain
wave gear
and there are three integrated sensors
here and the bespoke permanent magnet
machine
the linear actuator
I'm sorry
the linear actuator has planetary
rollers and an inverted planetary Screw
As a gear train which allows efficiency
and compaction and durability
so in order to demonstrate the force
capability of our linear actuators we
have set up an experiment in order to
test it under its limits
and
I will let you enjoy the video
so our actuator is able to lift
a half tone
nine foot concert grand piano
and
this is a requirement it's not something
nice to have because our muscles can do
the same when they are direct driven
when they are directly driven or
quadricep muscles can do the same thing
it's just that the knee is an up gearing
linkage system that converts the force
into velocity at the end effector of our
Hills for purposes of giving to the
human body agility
so this is one of the main things that
are amazing about the human body and I'm
concluding my part at this point and I
would like to welcome my colleague Mike
who's going to talk to you about hand
design thank you very much
thanks constantinos
so we just saw how powerful a human and
a humanoid actuator can be
however
humans are also incredibly dexterous
the human hand has the ability to move
at 300 degrees per second
it has tens of thousands of tactile
sensors
and it has the ability to grasp and
manipulate almost every object in our
daily lives
for our robotic hand design we were
inspired by biology
we have five fingers an opposable thumb
our fingers are driven by metallic
tendons that are both flexible and
strong
we have the ability to complete wide
aperture power grasps while also being
optimized for precision gripping of
small thin and delicate objects
so why a human like robotic hand
well the main reason is that our
factories and the world around us is
designed to be ergonomic
so what that means is that it ensures
that objects in our Factory are
graspable
but it also ensures that new objects
that we may have never seen before can
be grasped by the human hand and by our
robotic hand as well
the converse there is is pretty
interesting because it's saying that
these objects are designed to our hand
instead of having to make changes to our
hand to accompany a new object
some basic stats about our hand is that
has six actuators and 11 degrees of
freedom
it has an in-hand controller which
drives the fingers and receives sensor
feedback
sensor feedback is really important to
learn a little bit more about the
objects that we're grasping
and also for proprioception and that's
the ability for us to recognize where
our hand is in space
one of the important aspects of our hand
is that it's adaptive this adaptability
is involved essentially as complex
mechanisms that allow the hand to adapt
to the objects that's being grasped
another important part is that we have a
non-back drivable finger drive this
clutching mechanism allows us to hold
and transport objects without having to
turn on the hand Motors
you just heard how we went about going
we went about designing the Tesla bot
Hardware now we'll hand it off to Milan
and our autonomy team to bring this
robot to life
thanks Mike
all right
um so all those cool things we've shown
earlier in the video were posted
possible just in a matter of a few
months thanks to the amazing word that
we've done autopilot over the past few
years
most of those components ported quite
easily over to the Bots environment if
you think about it we're just moving
from a robot on Wheels to a robot on
legs so some of those components are
pretty similar and some other require
more heavy lifting
so for example our computer vision
neural networks
reported directly from autopilot to the
Bots situation
it's exactly the same occupancy Network
that we're talking to a little bit more
details later with the autopilot team
that is now running on the bot here in
this video the only thing that changed
really is the training data that we had
to recollect
we're also trying to find ways to
improve those occupancy networks using
work made on your Radiance fields to get
really great volumetric rendering of the
Bots environments for example here some
machine read that the bot might have to
interact with
another interesting problem to think
about is in indoor environments mostly
with that sense of GPS signal how do you
get about to navigate to its destination
say for instance to find its nearest
charging station so we've been training
more neural networks to identify high
frequency features key points within the
Bots camera streams and track them
across frames over time as the bot
navigates to its its environment
and we're using those points to get a
better estimate of the Bots pose and
trajectory within its environment as
it's walking
we also did quite some work on the
simulation side and this is literally
the autopilot simulator uh to which
we've integrated the robot's Locomotion
code and this is a video of the motion
control code running in the operator
simulator simulator showing the
evolution of the robots walk over time
and so as you can see we started quite
slowly in April and start accelerating
as we unlock more joints and deeper more
Advanced Techniques like arms balancing
over the past few months
and so Locomotion is specifically one
component that's very different as we're
moving from the car to the Bots
environment and so I think it warrants a
little bit more depth and I'd like my
colleagues to start talking about this
now
foreign
hi everyone I'm Felix I'm a robotics
engineer on the project and I'm going to
talk about walking
seems easy right people do it every day
you don't even have to think about it
but there are some aspects of walking
which are challenging from engineering
perspective for example
physical self-awareness that means
having a good representation of yourself
what is the length of your limbs what is
the mass of your limbs what is the size
of your feet all that matters
also having an energy efficient gate you
can imagine there's different styles of
walking and all of them are equally
efficient
most important keep balance don't fall
and of course also coordinate the motion
of all of your limbs together
so now humans do all of this naturally
but as Engineers or roboticists we have
to think about these problems and if I'm
going to show you how we address them in
our Locomotion planning and control
stack
so we start with Locomotion planning and
our representation of the bond that
means the model of the robot's
kinematics Dynamics and the contact
properties
and using that model and the desired
path for the Bots our Locomotion planner
generates reference trajectories for the
entire system
this means feasible trajectories with
respect to the assumptions of our model
the planner currently Works in three
stages it starts planning footsteps and
ends with the entire motion photo system
and let's dive a little bit deeper in
how this works so in this video we see
footsteps being planned over planning
Horizon following the desired path
and we start from this and add then for
trajectories that connect these
footsteps using toe off and yield strike
just as the humans just as humans do
and this gives us a larger stride and
less knee Bend for high efficiency of
the system
the last stage is then finding a center
of mass trajectory which gives us a fee
dynamically feasible motion of the
entire system to keep balance
as we all know plans are good but we
also have to realize them in reality
let's say you know see how we can do
this
[Applause]
thank you Felix hello everyone my name
is Anand and I'm going to talk to you
about controls
so let's take the motion plan that Felix
just talked about and put it in the real
world on a real robot let's see what
happens
it takes a couple steps
and falls down
well that's a little disappointing
but we are missing a few key pieces here
which will make it work
now as Felix mentioned the motion
planner is using an idealized version of
itself and a version of reality around
it
this is not exactly correct
it also expresses its intention through
trajectories and wrenches branches of
forces and torques that it wants to
exert on the World to locomote
reality is way more complex than any
similar model also the robot is not
simplified it's got vibrations and modes
compliance sensor noise and on and on
and on
so what does that do to the real world
when you put the bot in the real world
well the unexpected forces cause
unmodeled Dynamics which essentially the
planner doesn't know about and that
causes destabilization
especially For A system that is
dynamically stable like biped locomotion
so what can we do about it well we
measure reality
we use sensors and our understanding of
the world to do state estimation and
status to me here you can see the
attitude and pelvis pose which is
essentially the vestibular system in a
human
along with the center of mass trajectory
being tracked when the robot's walking
in the office environment
now we have all the pieces we need in
order to close the loop
so we use our better bot model
we use the understanding of reality that
we've gained through State estimation
and we compare what we want versus what
we expect the reality we expect that
reality is doing to us in order to
add corrections to the behavior of the
robot
here the robot certainly doesn't
appreciate being poked but it doesn't
admirable job of staying upright
the final Point here is a robot that
walks is not enough
we needed to use its hands and arms to
be useful let's talk about manipulation
[Applause]
hi everyone my name is Eric robotics
engineer on teslabot and I want to talk
about how we've made the robot
manipulate things in the real world
we wanted to manipulate objects while
looking as natural as possible and also
get there quickly so what we've done is
we've broken this process down into two
steps first is generating a library of
natural motion references or we could
call them demonstrations and then we've
adapted these motion references online
to the current real world situation
so let's say we have a human
demonstration of picking up an object
we can get a motion capture of that
demonstration which is visualized right
here as a bunch of keyframes
representing the locations of the hands
the elbows the Torso
we can map that to the robot using
inverse kinematics and if we collect a
lot of these now we have a library that
we can work with
but a single demonstration is not
generalizable to the variation in the
real world for instance this would only
work for a box in a very particular
location
so what we've also done is run these
reference trajectories through a
trajectory optimization program which
solves for where the hand should be how
the robot should balance
during uh when it needs to adapt the
motion to the real world so for instance
if the box is
in this location
then our Optimizer will create this
trajectory instead
next Milan's going to talk about uh
what's next for the Optimus uh Tesla y
thanks
thanks Larry
right so hopefully by now you guys got a
good idea of what we've been up to over
the past few months
um we started doing something that's
usable but it's far from being useful
there's still a long and exciting road
ahead of us
um
I think the first thing within the next
few weeks is to get Optimus at least at
par with Bumble C the other bug
prototype you saw earlier and probably
Beyond we're also going to start
focusing on the real use case at one of
our factories and really gonna try to
try to nail this down and I run out all
the elements needed to deploy this
product in the real world I was
mentioning earlier
um you know indoor navigation graceful
for management or even servicing all
components needed to scale this product
up
but um I don't know about you but after
seeing what we've shown tonight I'm
pretty sure we can get this done within
the next few months or years and I make
this product a reality and change the
entire economy so I would like to thank
the entire Optimus team for the hard
work over the past few months I think
it's pretty amazing all of this was done
in barely six or eight months thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you
hey everyone
hi I'm Ashok I lead the autopilot team
alongside Milan
God it's coming so hard to top that
Optimus section
he'll try nonetheless
anyway
um
every Tesla that has been built over the
last several years we think has the
hardware to make the car drive itself
we have been working on the software to
add higher and higher levels of autonomy
this time around last year we had
roughly 2 000 cars driving our FSD beta
software
since then we have significantly
improved the software as robustness and
capability that we have now shipped it
to 160 000 customers as of today
yep
[Applause]
this is not come for free it came from
the sweat and blood of the engineering
team over the last one year
for example we trained 75 000 neural
network models just last one year that's
roughly a model every eight minutes
that's you know coming out of the team
and then we evaluate them on our large
clusters and then we ship 281 of those
models that actually improve the
performance of the car
and this space of innovation is
happening throughout the stack
the the planning software the
infrastructure the tools even hiring
everything is progressing to the next
level
the FSG beta software is quite capable
of driving the car
it should be able to navigate from
parking lot to parking lot handling CDC
driving
stopping for traffic lights and stop
signs
negotiating with objects at
intersections making turns and so on
all of this comes from the camera
streams that go through our neural
networks that run on the car itself it's
not coming back to the server or
anything it runs on the car and produces
all the outputs to form the world model
around the car and the planning software
drives the car based on that
today we'll go into a lot of the
components that make up the system
the occupancy Network acts as the base
geometry layer of the system
this is a multi-camera video neural
network
that from the images predicts the full
physical occupancy of the world around
the robot
so anything that's physically present
trees walls buildings cars walls what
have you it predicts if it's
specifically present it predicts them
along with their future motion
on top of this base level of geometry we
have more semantic layers in order to
navigate the roadways we need the lens
of course
but then the roadways have lots of
different lanes and they connect in all
kinds of ways so it's actually a really
difficult problem for typical computer
vision techniques to predict the set of
planes and their connectivities
so we reached all the way into language
Technologies and then pulled the state
of the art from other domains and not
just computer vision to make this task
possible
for vehicles we need their full
kinematic state to control for them
all of this directly comes from neural
networks video streams raw video streams
come into the networks go through a lot
of processing and then outputs the full
kinematic state that positions
velocities acceleration jerk all of that
directly comes out of the networks with
minimal post processing that's really
fascinating to me because how how is
this even possible what world do we live
in that this magic is possible that
these networks predicts fourth
derivatives of these positions when
people thought we couldn't even detect
these objects
my opinion is that it did not come for
free uh it it required tons of data so
we had a bit sophisticated Auto labeling
systems that Shone through raw sensor
data run a ton of offline compute on the
servers it can take a few hours run
expensive neural networks distill the
information into labels that train our
in-car neural networks
on top of this we also use our
simulation system to synthetically
create images and since it's a
simulation we trivially have all the
labels
all of this goes through a well-oiled
data engine pipeline where we first
train a baseline model with some data
ship it to the car see what the failures
are and once you know the failures
we mine the fleet for the cases where it
fails provide the correct labels and add
the data to the training set
this process systematically fixes the
issues and we do this for every task
that runs in the car
yeah and to train these new massive
neural networks this year we expanded
our training infrastructure by roughly
40 to 50 percent so that sits us at
about 14 000 gpus today across multiple
training clusters in the United States
we also worked on our AI compiler which
now supports new operations needed by
those neural networks and map them to
the uh the best of our underlying
Hardware resources
and our inference engine today is
capable of Distributing the execution of
a single neural network across two
independent system on ships essentially
two independent computers interconnected
within the simple self-driving computer
and to make this possible we have to
keep a tight control on the end-to-end
latency of this new system so we
deployed more advanced scheduling code
across the full FSD platform
all of these neural networks running in
the car together produce the vector
space which is again the model of the
world around the robot or the car and
then the planning system operates on top
of this coming up with trajectories that
avoid collisions or smooth make progress
towards the destination using a
combination of model based optimization
plus neural network that helps optimize
it to be really fast
today we are really excited to present
progress on all of these areas we have
the engineering leads standing by to
come in and explain these various blocks
and these power not just the car but the
same components also run on the Optimus
robot that Milan showed earlier
with that I welcome panel to start
talking about the planning section
hi all I'm parel joint
let's use this intersection scenario to
dive straight into how we do the
planning and decision making in
autopilot
so we are approaching this intersection
from a side street and we have to yield
to all the crossing vehicles
rightness as we are about to enter the
intersection
The Pedestrian on the other side of the
intersection decides to cross the road
without a crosswalk
now we need to yield to this pedestrian
yield to the vehicles from the right and
also understand the relation between The
Pedestrian and the vehicle on the other
side of the intersection
so a lot of these intra-object
dependencies that we need to resolve in
a quick glance
and humans are really good at this we
look at a scene understand all the
possible interactions evaluate the most
promising ones
and generally end up choosing a
reasonable one
so let's look at a few of these
interactions that autopilot system
evaluated
we could have gone in front of this
pedestrian with a very aggressive launch
in a lateral profile
now obviously we are being a jerk to The
Pedestrian and we would spook The
Pedestrian and his cute pet
we could have moved forward slowly short
for a gap between The Pedestrian or and
the vehicle from the right
again we are being a jerk to the vehicle
coming from the right but you should not
outright reject this interaction in case
this is only safe interaction available
lastly the interaction we ended up
choosing
stay slow initially find the reasonable
Gap and then finish the maneuver after
all the agents pass
now evaluation of all of these
interactions is not trivial
especially when you care about modeling
the higher order derivatives for other
agents
for example what is the longitudinal
jerk required by the vehicle coming from
the right when you assert in front of it
relying purely on collision checks with
modular predictions will only get you so
far because you will miss out on a lot
of valid interactions
this basically boils down to solving a
multi-agent joint trajectory planning
problem over the trajectories of ego and
all the other agents
now how much ever you optimize there's
going to be a limit to how fast you can
run this optimization problem it will be
close to close to order of 10
milliseconds even after a lot of
incremental approximations
now for a typical crowded unpredictable
left
say you have more than 20 objects each
object having multiple different future
modes the number of relevant interaction
combinations will blow up
we the planner needs to make a decision
every 50 milliseconds so how do we solve
this in real time
we rely on a framework what we call as
interaction search which is basically a
parallelized research over a bunch of
maneuver trajectories
the state space here corresponds to the
kinematic state of ego the kinematic
state of other agents the nominal future
multiple multimodal predictions and all
the static entities in the scene
the action space is where things get
interesting
we use a set of maneuver trajectory
candidates to Branch over a bunch of
interactional decisions
and also incremental goals for a longer
Horizon maneuver
Let's Walk Through This research very
quickly to get a sense of how it works
we start with a set of vision
measurements namely Lanes occupancy
moving objects these get represented as
sparse extractions as well as latent
features
we use this to create a set of goal
candidates
Lanes again from the lanes Network or
unstructured regions which correspond to
a probability mask derived from Human
demonstrations
once we have a bunch of these gold
candidates we create seed trajectories
using a combination of classical
optimization approaches as well as our
Network planner again trained on data
from the customer feed
now once we get a bunch of these free
trajectories we use them to start
branching on the interactions
we find the most critical interaction
in our case this would be the
interaction with respect to The
Pedestrian whether we assert in front of
it or yield to it
obviously the option on the left is a
high penalty option it likely won't get
prioritized so we Branch further onto
the option on the right and that's where
we bring in more and more complex
interactions building this optimization
problem incrementally with more and more
constraints
and that research keeps flowing
branching on more interactions branching
on more goals
now a lot of tricks here lie in
evaluation of each of each of this node
of the research
inside each node
initially we started with creating
trajectories using classical
optimization approaches where the
constraints like I described would be
added incrementally
and this would take close to one to five
milliseconds per action
now even though this is fairly good
number when you want to evaluate more
than 100 interactions this does not
scale
so we ended up building lightweight
queryable networks that you can run in
the loop of the planner
these networks are trained on human
demonstrations from the fleet as well as
offline solvers with relaxed time limits
with this we were able to bring the
rundown runtime down to close 200
microseconds per action
now doing this alone is not enough
because you still have this massive
research that that you need to go
through and you need to efficiently
prune the search space
so you need to do a do scoring on each
of these trajectories few of these are
fairly standard you do a bunch of
collision checks you do a bunch of
comfort analysis what is the jerk and
actually required for a given maneuver
the customer Fleet data plays an
important role here again
we run two sets of again lightweight
variable networks both really augmenting
each other one of them trained from
interventions from the FST beta Fleet
which gives a score on How likely is a
given maneuver to result in
interventions over the next few seconds
and second which is purely on human
demonstrations human driven data giving
a score on how close is your given
selected action to a human driven
trajectory
the scoring helps us prune the search
space
keep branching further on the
interactions and focus the compute on
the most promising outcomes
the the cool part about this
architecture is that it allows us to
create a cool blend between
uh data driven approaches where you
don't have to rely on a lot of hand
engineered costs but also ground it in
reality with physics-based checks
now a lot of what what I described was
with respect to the agents we could
observe in the scene but the same
framework extends to objects behind
occlusions
we use the video feed from eight cameras
to generate the 3D occupancy of the
world
the blue mask here corresponds to the
visibility region we call it
it basically gets blocked at the first
occlusion you see in the scene we
consume this visibility mask to generate
what we call as ghost objects which you
can see on the top left
now if you model the spawn regions and
the state transitions of this ghost
objects correctly
if you tune your control response as a
function of that existence likelihood
you can extract some really nice
human-like behaviors
now I'll pass it on on to fill to
describe more on how we generate these
occupancy Networks
hey guys my name is Phil uh I will share
the details of the occupancy Network we
build over the past year
this network is our solution to model
the physical work in 3D around our cars
and it is currently not shown in our
customer facing visualization and what
we will see here is the road Network
output from our internal Dev tool
the occupancy Network takes video
streams of all our 80 cameras as input
produces a single unified volumetric
occupancy in Vector space directly
for every 3D location around our car it
predicts the probability of that
location being occupied a lot
since it has video contacts it is
capable of predicting obstacles that are
occluded instantaneously
for each location it also produces a set
of semantics such as curb car pedestrian
and low debris as color coded here
occupancy flow is also predicted for
motion
since the model is a generalized Network
it does not tell static and dynamic
objects
explicitly it is able to produce and
model the random motions such as the
swerving trainer here
this network is currently running in all
Teslas with FSD computers and it is
incredibly efficient runs about every 10
milliseconds with our neural accelerator
so how does this work let's take a look
at the architecture
first we Rectify each camera images with
the camera calibration
and the images were shown here were
given to the network it's actually not
the typical 8-bit RGB image as you can
see from the first imagery on top we're
giving the 12 bit raw photo account
image to the network since it has four
bits more information it has 16 times
better dynamic range as well as reduced
latency since we don't have the wrong
ISP in Adobe anymore
we use a set of records and back with
FPS as a backbone to extract images
space features
next we construct a set of 3D position
query along with the IMG space features
as keys and values fit into an attention
module
the output of the attention module is
high dimensional spatial features
these special features are aligned
temporarily using vehicle odometry
to derive motion
last this spatial temporal features go
through a set of D convolution to
produce the final occupancy and
occupancy flow output
they're formed as fixed size boxer gray
which might not be precise enough for
planning on control
in order to get a higher resolution we
also produce per voxel feature Maps
which will feed into MLP with 3D spatial
Point queries to get position and
semantics at any arbitrary location
after knowing the model better let's
take a look at another example here we
have an articular bus parked along right
side row highlighted as a L-shaped boxer
here as we approach the bus starts to
move the blue the front of the cart
turns blue first indicating the model
predicts the frontal bus has a down zero
occupancy flow
and the s-bus keeps moving the entire
bus turns blue
and you can also see that the network
predicts the precise curvature of the
bus
well this is a very complicated problem
for traditional object detection Network
as you have to see whether I'm going to
use one cuboid or perhaps a two to fit
the curvature but for occupation Network
since all we care about is the occupancy
in the visible space and we'll be able
to model the curvature precisely
besides the voxel grade the occupancy
Network also produces a drivable surface
the drivable surface has both 3D
geometry and semantics they are very
useful for control especially on healing
and curvy roads
the surface and the voxel gray are not
predicted independently instead the
voxel grid actually aligns with the
surface implicitly
here we are at a hero Quest where you
can see the 3D geometry of the surface
being predicted nicely
planner can use this information to
decide perhaps we need to slow down more
for the Hillcrest and as you can also
see the voxel grade aligns with the
surface consistently
besides the Box source and the surface
we're also very excited about the recent
breakthrough in neural readings field or
Nerf
we're looking into both incorporate some
of the light color features into
occupancy Network training as well as
using our Network output as the input
state for Nerf
as a matter of fact Ashok is very
excited about this this has been his uh
personal weekend project for a while
on these nerves because I think the
Academia is building a lot of these
Foundation models uh for language using
like tons of large data sets for
language but I think for vision nerves
are going to provide the foundation
models for computer vision because they
are grounded in geometry and geometry
gives us a nice way to supervise these
networks and freezes of the requirement
to Define an ontology and the
supervision is essentially free because
you just have to differentiably render
these images
so I think in the future uh this
occupancy Network idea where you know
images come in and then the network
produces a consistent
volumetric representation of the scene
that can then be differentially rendered
into any image that was observed I I
personally think is a future of computer
vision uh and you know we do some
initial work on it uh right now but I
think in the future both at Tesla and in
the Academia we will see that these
combination of One-Shot prediction of
volumetric occupancy uh will be that's
my personal bet
sexual
so here's an example early result of a
3D Reconstruction from our free data
instead of focusing on getting perfect
RGB reprojection in imaging space our
primary goal here is to accurately
represent the warnings 3D space for
driving and we want to do this for all
our free data over the world in all
weather and lighting conditions and
obviously this is a very challenging
problem and we're looking for you guys
to help
finally the occupancy network is trained
with large auto level data set without
any human in the loop
and with that I'll pass to Tim to talk
about what it takes to train this
network
thanks Phil
[Applause]
all right hey everyone
let's talk about some training
infrastructure
so we've seen a couple of videos you
know four or five uh I think and care
more and worry more about a lot more
Clips on that so we've been looking at
the occupancy networks just from Phil
just fills videos it takes 1.4 billion
frames to train that Network what you
just saw and if you have a hundred
thousand gpus uh it would take one hour
but if you have uh one GPU it would take
a hundred thousand hours so that is not
a Humane time period that you can wait
for your training job to run right we
want to ship faster than that so that
means you're going to need to go
parallel so you need a more compute for
that that means you're going to need a
supercomputer so this is why we've built
in-house three supercomputers comprising
of 14 000 gpus where we use 10 000 gpus
for training and around four thousand
gpus for auto labeling
all these videos are stored in 30
petabytes of a distributed managed video
cache
you shouldn't think of our data sets as
fixed let's say as you think of your
imagenet or something you know with like
a million frames you should think of it
as a very fluid thing so we've got a
half a million of these videos flowing
in and out of this cluster these
clusters every single day
and we track 400 000 of these kind of
python video instantiations every second
so that is that's a lot of calls we're
gonna need to capture that in order to
govern the retention policies of this
distributed video cache so underlying
all of this is a huge amount of infra
all of which we build and manage
in-house
so you cannot just buy you know 40 000
gpus and then a 30 petabytes of Flash
mvme and just put it together and let's
go train uh it actually takes a lot of
work and I'm gonna go into a little bit
of that
what you actually typically want to do
is you want to take your accelerator so
that it could be the GPU or Dojo which
we'll talk about later
and because that's the most expensive
component that's where you want to put
your bottleneck and so that means that
every single part of your system is
going to need to outperform this
accelerator
and so that is really complicated that
means that your storage is going to need
to have the size and the bandwidth to
deliver all the data down into the nodes
these nodes need to have the right
amount of CPU and memory capabilities to
feed into your machine learning
framework
this machine learning framework then
needs to hand it off to your GPU and
then you can start training but then you
need to do so across hundreds or
thousands of GPU in a reliable way in
logstap and in a way that's also fast so
you're also going to need an
interconnect
extremely complicated we'll talk more
about dojo in a second
so first I want to take you to some
optimizations that we've done on our
cluster
so we're getting in a lot of videos and
video is very much unlike let's say
training on images or text which I think
is very well established video is quite
literally a dimension more complicated
um and so that's why we needed to go end
to end from the storage layer down to
the accelerator and optimize every
single piece of that
because we train on the photon count
videos that come directly from our Fleet
we train on those directly we do not
post process those at all
the way it's just done is we seek
exactly to the frames we select for our
batch we load those in including the
frames that they depend on so these are
your iframes or your keyframes we
package those up move them into shared
memory move them into a double bar from
the GPU and then use the hardware
decoder that's only accelerated to
actually decode the video so we do that
on the GPU natively and this is all in a
very nice python pytorch extension
doing so unlocked more than 30 training
speed increase for the occupancy
networks and freed up basically a whole
CPU to do any other thing
um you cannot just do training with just
videos of course you need some kind of a
ground Truth uh and uh that is actually
an interesting problem as well the
objective for storing your ground truth
is that you want to make sure you get to
your ground truth that you need in the
minimal amount of file system operations
and load in the minimal size of what you
need in order to optimize for aggregate
cross cluster throughput because you
should see a compute cluster as one big
device which has internally fixed
constraints and thresholds
so for this we rolled out a format that
is native to us that's called small we
use this for our ground truth our
feature cache and any inference outputs
so a lot of tensors that are in there
and so just the cartoon here let's say
these are your uh is your table that you
want to store then that's how that would
look out if you rolled out on disk so
what you do is you take anything you'd
want to index on so for example video
timestamps you put those all in the
header so that in your initial header
read you know exactly where to go on
disk then if you have any tensors
uh you're going to try to transpose the
dimensions to put a different dimension
last as the contiguous Dimension and
then also try different types of
compression then you check out which one
was most optimal and then store that one
this is actually a huge step if you do
feature caching
unintelligible output from the machine
Learning Network rotate around the
dimensions a little bit you can get up
to 20 increase in efficiency of storage
then when you store that we also
ordered the columns by size so that all
your small columns and small values are
together so that when you seek for a
single value you're likely to overlap
with a read on more values which you'll
use later so that you don't need to do
another file system operation
so I could go on and on I just went on
on touched on two projects that we have
internally but this is actually part of
a huge continuous effort to optimize the
compute that we have in-house so
accumulating and aggregating through all
these optimizations We Now train our
occupancy networks twice as fast just
because it's twice as efficient and now
if we add in bunch more compute and go
parallel we cannot train this in hours
instead of days
and with that I'd like to hand it off to
the biggest user of compute John
hi everybody my name is John Emmons I
lead the autopilot Vision team
I'm going to cover two topics with you
today
the first is how we predict lanes and
the second is how we predict the future
behavior of other agents on the road
in the early days of autopilot we
modeled the lane detection problem as an
image space instant segmentation task
our network was super simple though in
fact it was only capable of printing
Lanes from of a few different kinds of
geometries specifically it would segment
the Eagle Lane it could segment adjacent
lanes and then it had some special
casing for forks and merges
this simplistic modeling of the problem
worked for highly structured roads like
highways
but today we're trying to build a system
that's capable of much more complex
Maneuvers specifically we want to make
left and right turns at intersections
where the road topology can be quite a
bit more complex and diverse when we try
to apply this simplistic modeling of the
problem here it just totally breaks down
taking a step back for a moment what
we're trying to do here is to predict
the spark set of lame instances in their
connectivity
and what we want to do is to have a
neural network that basically predicts
this graph where the nodes are the lane
segments and the edges encode the
connectivities between these Lanes
so what we have is our lane detection
neural network
it's made up of three components
in the first component we have a set of
convolutional layers attention layers
and other neural network layers that
encode the video streams from our eight
cameras on the vehicle and produce a
rich visual representation
we then enhance this digital
representation with a coarse roadmap
Road level map data which we encode with
a set of additional neural network
layers that we call the lane guidance
module
this map is not an HD map but it
provides a lot of useful hints about the
topology of lanes inside of
intersections the lane counts on various
roads and a set of other attributes that
help us
the first two components here produced a
dense tensor that sort of encodes the
world but what we really want to do is
to convert this dense tensor into a
smart set of lanes in their
connectivities
we approach this problem like an image
captioning task where the input is this
dense tensor and the output text is
predicted into a special language that
we developed at Tesla for encoding Lanes
in their connectivities
in this language of lanes the words and
tokens are the lane positions in 3D
space
in The Ordering of the tokens
introducted modifiers in the tokens
encode the connective relationships
between these Lanes
by modeling the task as a language
problem we can capitalize on recent
autoregressive architectures
and techniques from the language
Community for handling the multiple
modality of the problem
we're not just solving the computer
vision problem at autopilot we're also
applying the state-of-the-art and
language modeling and machine learning
more generally
I'm now going to dive into a little bit
more detail this language component
what I have depicted on the screen here
is the satellite image which sort of
represents the local area around the
vehicle
the set of nosing edges is what we refer
to as the lane graph and it's ultimately
what we want to come out of this neural
network
we start with a blank slate
we're going to want to make our first
prediction here at this Green Dot
this green dots position is encoded as
an index into a course grid which
discretizes the 3D World
now we don't predict this index directly
because it would be too computationally
expensive to do so there's just too many
grid points and predicting a categorical
distribution over this has both
implications at training time and test
time
so instead what we do is we disretch the
world coarsely first we predict a heat
map over the possible locations and then
we latch in the most probable location
on this we then refine the prediction
and get the precise point
now we know where the position of this
token is we don't know its type in this
case though it's the beginning of a new
Lane
so we approach it as a start token
and because it's a star token there's no
additional attributes in our language
we then take the predictions from this
first forward pass and we encode them
using a learned additional embedding
which produces a set of tensors that we
combine together
which is actually the first word in our
language of lanes we add this to the you
know first position in our sentence here
we then continue this process by
printing the next Lane point in a
similar fashion
now this Lane point is not the beginning
of a new Lane it's actually a
continuation of the previous Lane
so it's a continuation token type
now it's not enough just to know that
this Lane is connected to the previously
protected plane we want to encode its
precise geometry which we do by
regressing a set of spline coefficients
we then take this Lane we encode it
again and add it as the next word in the
sentence
we continue predicting these
continuation Lanes until we get to the
end of the prediction grid
we then move on to a different Lane
segment
so you can see that cyan dot there now
it's it's not topologically connected to
that pink point it's actually forking
off of that that blue sorry that green
point there
so it's got a fork type and Fork tokens
actually point back to previous tokens
from which the fork originates so you
can see here the fork Point predictor is
actually the index zero so it's actually
referencing back to tokens that it's
already predicted like you would in
language
we continue this process over and over
again until we've enumerated all of the
tokens in the Ling graph and then the
network predicts the end of sentence
token
yeah I just want to note that the reason
we do this is not just because we want
to build something complicated it's
almost feels like a turing complete
machine here with neural networks though
is that we tried simple approaches for
example uh trying to just segment the
lanes along the road or something like
that but then the problem is when
there's uncertainty say you cannot see
the road clearly and there could be two
lanes or three lanes and you can't tell
a simple segmentation based approach
would just draw both of them
is kind of a 2.5 Lane situation and the
post processing algorithm would
hilariously fail when the predictions
are such
yeah the problems don't end there I mean
you need to predict these connective
conditions like these connective Lanes
inside of intersections which it's just
not possible with the approach that
ashok's mentioning which is why we had
to upgrade to this sort of like overlaps
like this segmentation would just go
Haywire but even if you try very hard to
you know put them on separate layers
it's just a really hard problem what
language just offers a really nice
framework for modern getting a
sample from a posterior as opposed to
you know trying to do all of this in
post-processing
but this doesn't actually stop for just
autopilot right John this can be used
for Optimus
again you know I guess they wouldn't be
called Lanes but you could imagine you
know sort of in this you know stage here
that you might have sort of paths that
sort of you know encode the possible
places that people could walk
yeah it's basically if you're in a
factory or in a you know home setting
you can just ask the robot okay let me
please talk to the kitchen or please
route to some location in the factory
and then we predict a set of Pathways
that would you know go through the
aisles take the robot and say okay this
is how you get to the kitchen it just
really gives us a nice framework to
model these different paths that
simplify the navigation problem or the
downstream planner
all right so ultimately what we get from
this Lane detection network is a set of
lanes in their connectivities which
comes directly from the network there's
no additional step here for as far
simplifying these you know dense
predictions into into indispersed ones
this is just a direct unfiltered output
of the network
okay so I talked a little bit about
Lanes I'm going to briefly touch on how
we model and predict the future paths in
other semantics on objects
so I'm just going to go really quickly
through two examples the video on the
right here we've got a car that's
actually running a red light and turning
in front of us what we do to handle
situations like this is we predict a set
of short time Horizon future
trajectories on all objects we can use
these to anticipate the dangerous
situation here and apply whatever you
know braking and steering action is
required to avoid a collision
in the video on the right there's two
vehicles in front of us the one on the
left lane is parked apparently it's
being loaded unloaded I don't know why
the driver decided to park there but the
important thing is that our neural
network predicted that it was stopped
which is the red color there
um the vehicle in the other lane as you
notice also is stationary but that one's
obviously just waiting for that red
light to turn green so even though both
objects are stationary and have zero
velocity it's the semantics that is
really important here so that we don't
get stuck behind that awkwardly parked
car
predicting all of these agent attributes
presents some practical problems when
trying to build a real-time system
we need to maximize the frame rate of
our object section stack so that
autopilot can quickly react to the
changing environment
every millisecond really matters here
to minimize the inference latency our
neural network is split into two phases
in the first phase we identified
locations in 3D space where agents exist
in the second stage we then pull out
tensors at those 3D locations append it
with additional data that's on the
vehicle and then we you know do the rest
of the processing
this specification step allows the
neural network to focus compute on the
areas that matter most which gives us
Superior performance for a fraction of
the latency cost
so putting it all together
the autopilot Vision stack predicts more
than just the geometry and kinematics of
the world it also predicts a rich set of
semantics which enables safe and
human-like driving
I'm not going to hand things off to
Street we'll tell us how we run all
these cool neural networks on our FSD
computer thank you
[Applause]
hi everyone I'm SRI
today I'm going to give glimpse of what
it takes to run this FSC networks in the
car and how do we optimize for the
inference latency
uh today I'm going to focus just on the
FSG Lanes Network that John just talked
about
so when you started this track we wanted
to know if we can run this FSC Lanes
Network natively on the trip engine
which is our in-house neural network
accelerator that we built in the FSD
computer
when we build this Hardware we kept it
simple and we made sure it can do one
thing ridiculously fast dense dot
products but this architecture is auto
regressive and iterative where it
crunches through multiple attention
attention blocks in the Inner Loop
producing sparse points directly at
every step so the challenge here was how
can we do this parse Point prediction
and sparse computation on a dense dot
product engine let's see how we did this
on the trip
so the network predicts the heat map of
most probable spatial locations of the
point now we do a Arc Max and a one
heart operation which gives the one hard
encoding of the index of the spatial
location
now we need to select the embedding
associated with this index from an
embedding table that is learned during
training
to do this on trip we actually built a
lookup table in SRAM and we engineered
the dimensions of this embedding such
that we could achieve all of this thing
with just matrix multiplication
not just that we also wanted to store
this embedding into a token cache so
that we don't recompute this for every
iteration rather reuse it for future
Point prediction again we pulled some
tricks here where we did all these
operations just on the dot product
engine it's actually cool that our team
found creative ways to map all these
operations on the trip engine in ways
that were not even imagined when this
Hardware was designed
but that's not the only thing we have to
do to make this work we actually
implemented a whole lot of operations
and features to make this model
compilable to improve the intake
accuracy as well as to optimize
performance
all of these things helped us run the 75
million parameter model just under 10
millisecond of latency consuming just 8
watts of power
but this is not the only architecture
running in the car there are so many
other architectures modules and networks
we need to run in the car
to give a sense of scale there are about
a billion parameters of all the networks
combined producing around 1000 neural
network signals so we need to make sure
we optimize them jointly and
such that we maximize the compute
utilization throughput and minimize the
latency
so we built a compiler just for neural
networks that shares the structure to
traditional compilers
as you can see it takes the massive
graph of neural Nets with 150k nodes and
375k connection takes this thing
partitions them into independent
subgraphs and com compels each of those
subgraphs natively for the inference
devices then we have a neural network
Linker which shares the structure to
traditional Linker where we perform this
link time optimization
there we solve an offline optimization
problem
uh for with compute memory and memory
bandwidth constraints so that it comes
with an optimized schedule that gets
executed in the car
on the runtime we designed a hybrid
scheduling system which basically does
heterogeneous scheduling on one SOC and
distributed scheduling across both the
socs to run these networks in a model
parallel fashion
to get 100 drops of compute utilization
we need to optimize across all the
layers of software right from tuning the
network architecture the compiler all
the way to implementing a low latency
high bandwidth RDMA link across both the
srcs and in fact going even deeper to
understanding and optimizing the cache
coherent and non-coherent data Paths of
the accelerator in the soc this is a lot
of optimization at every level in order
to make sure we get the highest frame
rate and as every millisecond counts
here
and this is this is just the this is the
visualization of the neural networks
that are running in the car this is our
digital brain essentially as you can see
these operations are nothing but just
the matrix multiplication convolution to
name a few
real operations running in the car
to train or train this network with a
billion parameters you need a lot of
labeled data so aegon is going to talk
about how do we achieve this with the
auto labeling pipeline
thank you
uh
thank you Sherry
uh hi everyone I'm Jurgen Zhang and I'm
leading a geometric Vision at autopilot
so
yeah let's talk about Auto labeling
so we have several kinds of all the
labeling Frameworks to support various
types of networks but today I'd like to
focus on the awesome Lanes net here
so to successfully train and generalize
this network to everywhere we think we
went tens of millions of trips from
probably one one million intersection or
even more
so
then how to do that so it is certainly
achievable uh to Source sufficient
amount of trips because we already have
as Tim explained earlier we already have
like 500 000 trips per day cash rate
um however converting all those data
into a training form is a very
challenging technical problem
to solve this challenge we tried various
ways of manual and auto labeling so from
the First Column to the second from the
second to the third each Advance
provided us nearly 100x Improvement in
throughput
but still uh we won an even better Auto
labeling machine that can provide
provide providers good quality diversity
and scalability
to meet all these requirements uh
despite the huge amount of engineering
effort required here we've developed a
new order labeling machine powered by
multi-trib reconstruction
so this can replace 5 million hours of
manual labeling with just 12 hours on
cluster for labeling 10 000 trips
so how we solved there are three big
steps the first step is high Precision
trajectory and structure recovery by
multi-camera visual inertial odometry
so here all the features including
ground surface are inferred from videos
by neural networks then tracked and
reconstructed in the vector space
so the typical drift rate of this
trajectory in car is like 1.3 centimeter
per meter and 0.45 Milli radian per
meter which is pretty decent uh
considering its compact compute
requirement
than the recovery service and raw
details are also used as a strong
guidance for the later manual
verification step
this is also enabled in every FSD
vehicle so we get pre-processed
trajectories and structures along with
the trip data
the second step is multi-2
reconstruction which is the big and core
piece of this machine
so the video shows how the previously
shown trip is reconstructed and aligned
with other trips basically other trips
from different people not the same
vehicle so this is done by multiple
internet steps like course alignment
pairwise matching joint optimization
then further surface refinement
in the end the human analyst comes in
and finalizes the label
so each happy steps are already fully
parallelized on the cluster so the
entire process usually takes just a
couple of hours
the last step is actually Auto labeling
the new trips so
here we use the same multi-trip
alignment engine but only between
pre-built reconstruction and each new
trip so it's much much simpler than
fully reconstructing all the clips
altogether
that's why it only takes 30 minutes per
trip to other label instead of manual
several hours of manual labeling
and this is also the key of scalability
of this machine
this machine easily scales as long as we
have available compute and trip data
so about 50 trees were newly order
labeled from this scene and some of them
are shown here so 53 from different
vehicles
so this is how we capture and transform
the space-time slices of the world into
the network supervision
yeah one thing I like to note is that
again just talked about how we Auto
label our lanes but we have Auto
laborers for almost every task that we
do including our planner and many of
these are fully automatic like no humans
involved for example for objects or
other kinematics the shapes their
Futures everything just comes from Auto
labeling and the same is true for
occupancy too and we have really just
built a machine around this yeah so if
you can go back one slide
not one more
it says parallelized on cluster so so
that sounds pretty straightforward but
it really wasn't
um maybe it's it's fun to share how
something like this comes about
um so a while ago we didn't have any
auto labeling at all and then someone
makes a script it starts to work it
starts working better until we reach a
volume that's pretty high and we clearly
need a solution
and so there were two other engineers in
our team who were like you know that's
an interesting you know uh thing what we
needed to do was build a whole graph of
essentially
python functions that we need to run one
after the other first you pull the clip
then you do some cleaning then you do
some Network inference then another
Network inference until you finally get
this but so you need to do this as a
large scale so I so I tell them we
probably need to shoot for you know 100
000 Clips per day or like 100 000 items
that seems good
um and so the engineers say well we can
do you know a bit of postgres and a bit
of elbow grease we can do it meanwhile
we are a bit later and we're doing 20
million of these functions every single
day
again we pull in around half a million
clips and on those we run a ton of
functions each of these in a streaming
fashion and so that's kind of the back
end infra that's also needed to not just
run training but also Auto labeling yeah
it really is like a factory that
produces labels and like production
lines yield quality uh inventory like
all of the same Concepts applied to this
label Factory uh that applies for you
know the factory for our cars that's
right
okay uh thanks uh so yeah so concluding
this section uh I'd like to share a few
more challenging and interesting
examples for Network for sure and even
for humans probably uh so from the top
there's like examples for like lack of
Lies case or foggy night or roundabout
and occlusions by heavy occlusions by
parked cars and even rainy night with
their raindrops on camera lenses uh
these are challenging but once their
original scenes are fully reconstructed
by other clips they all of them can be
Auto labeled so that our cards can drive
even better through these challenging
scenarios
so now let me pass the mic to David to
learn more about how Sim is creating the
new world on top of these labels thank
you
thank you again my name is David and I'm
going to talk about simulation
so simulation plays a critical role in
providing data that is difficult to
source and or hard to label
however 3D scenes are notoriously slow
to produce take for example the
simulated scene playing behind me a
complex
intersection from Market Street in San
Francisco it would take two weeks for
artists to complete and for us that is
painfully slow
however I'm going to talk about using
jaegan's automated ground truth labels
along with some brand new tooling that
allows us to procedurally generate this
scene and many like it in just five
minutes that's an amazing a thousand
times faster than before
so let's dive in to our scene like this
is created
we start by piping the automated ground
truth labels into our simulated World
creator tooling inside the software
Houdini starting with Road boundary
labels we can generate a solid Road mesh
and re-topologize it with the lane graph
labels this helps inform important Road
details like Crossroads slope and
detailed material blending
next we can use the line data and sweep
geometry across its surface and project
it to the road creating Lane paint
decals
next using median edges we can spawned
Island geometry and populate it with
randomized foliage this drastically
changes the visibility of the scene
now the outside world can be generated
through a series of randomized
heuristics a modular building generators
create visual obstructions while
randomly placed objects like hydrants
can change the color of the curves while
trees can drop leaves below it obscuring
lines or edges
next we can bring in map data to inform
positions of things like traffic traffic
lights or stop signs we can trace along
its normal to collect important
information like number of lanes and
even get accurate street names on the
signs themselves
next using Lane graph we can determine
Lane connectivity and spawn directional
Road markings on the road and they're
accompanying road signs
and finally with Lane graph itself we
can determine Lane adjacency and other
useful metrics to spawn randomized
traffic permutations Insider simulator
and again this is all automatic no
artists in the loop and happens within
minutes and now this sets us up to do
some pretty cool things
since everything is based on data and
heuristics we can start to fuzz
parameters to create visual variations
of the single ground truth it can be as
subtle as object placement and random
material swapping to more drastic
changes like entirely new biomes or
locations of environment like Urban
Suburban or rural
this allows us to create infinite
targeted permutations for specific
ground truths that we need
more ground Truth for
and all this happens within a click of a
button
and we can even take this one step
further by altering our ground truth
itself
say John wants his Network to pay more
attention the directional Road markings
to better detect an upcoming captive
left turn lane we can start to
procedurally alter our lane graph inside
the simulator
to help folk to create entirely new
flows through this intersection to help
Focus the Network's attention to the
road markings to create more accurate
predictions
and this is a great example of how this
tooling allows us to create new data
that could never be collected from The
Real World
and the true power of this tool
is in its architecture and how we can
run all tasks in parallel to infinitely
scale
so you saw the tile Creator tool in
action converting the ground truth
labels into their counterparts
next we can use our tile extractor tool
to divide this data into geohash tiles
about 150 meters square in size
we then save out that data into separate
geometry and instance files this gives
us a clean source of data that's easy to
load and allows us to be rendering
engine agnostic for the future
then using a tile loader tool we can
summon any number of those cache tiles
using a geohash ID currently we're doing
about these five by five tiles or three
by three usually centered around Fleet
hotspots or interesting land graph
locations
in the tile loader also converts these
tile sets into U assets for consumption
by the Unreal Engine and gives you a
finished project product from what you
saw in the first slide
and this really sets us up for size and
scale as you can see on the map behind
us
we can easily generate most of San
Francisco city streets and this didn't
take years or even months of work but
rather two weeks by one person
we can continue to manage and grow all
this data using our PDG Network inside
of the tooling this allows us to throw
compute at it and regenerate all these
tile sets overnight
this ensures all environments are of
consistent quality and features which is
super important for training since new
ontologies and signals are constantly
released
and now to come full circle because we
generated all these tile sets from
ground truth data that contain all the
weird intricacies from The Real World
and we can combine that with the
procedural Visual and traffic variety to
create Limitless targeted data for the
network to learn from
and that concludes the Sim section I'll
pass it to Kate to talk about how we can
use all this data to improve autopilot
thank you
thanks David hi everyone my name is Kate
Park and I'm here to talk about the data
engine which is the process by which we
improve our neural networks via data
we're going to show you how we
deterministically solve interventions
via data and walk you through the life
of this particular clip in this scenario
autopilot is approaching a turn and
incorrectly predicts that Crossing
vehicle as stopped for traffic and thus
a vehicle that we would slow down for in
reality there's nobody in the car it's
just awkwardly parked we've built this
tooling to identify the mispredictions
correct the label and categorize this
clip into an evaluation set this
particular clip happens to be one of 126
that we've diagnosed as challenging
parked cars at turns because of this
infra we can curate this evaluation set
without any engineering resources custom
to this particular challenge case
to actually solve that challenge case
requires mining thousands of examples
like it and it's something Tesla can
trivially do we simply use our data
sourcing infra request data and use the
tooling shown previously to correct the
labels
by surgically targeting the
mispredictions of the current model
we're only adding the most valuable
examples to our training set
we surgically fix 13 900 clips and uh
because those were examples where the
current model struggles we don't even
need to change the model architecture a
simple way update with this new valuable
data is enough to solve the challenge
case so you see we no longer predict
that Crossing vehicle as stopped as
shown in Orange but parked as shown in
red
in Academia we often see that people
keep data constant but at Tesla it's
very much the opposite we see time and
time and again that data is one of the
best if not the most deterministic lever
to solving these interventions
we just showed you the data engine Loop
for one challenge case namely these
parked cars at turns but there are many
challenge cases even for one signal of
vehicle Movement we apply this data
engine Loop to every single challenge
case we've diagnosed whether it's buses
curvy roads stopped Vehicles parking
lots and we don't just add data once we
do this again and again to perfect the
semantic in fact this year we updated
our vehicle movement signal five times
and with every weight update trained on
the new data we push our vehicle
movement accuracy up and up
this data engine framework applies to
all our signals whether they're 3D
multi-cam video whether the data is
human labeled Auto labeled or simulated
whether it's an offline model or an
online model model and Tesla is able to
do this at scale because of the fleet
Advantage the infra that our engine team
has built and the labeling resources
that feed our Networks
to train on all this data we need a
massive amount of compute so I'll hand
it off to Pete and Ganesh to talk about
the dojo supercomputing platform thank
you
[Applause]
thank you
thank you Katie
thanks everybody thanks for hanging in
there we're almost there
my name is Pete Bannon I run the custom
silicon and low voltage teams at Tesla
and my name is Ganesh venkat I run the
doji program
[Applause]
thank you
I'm frequently asked why is a car
company building a super computer for
training
and this question fundamentally
misunderstands the nature of Tesla at
its heart Tesla is a hardcore technology
company
all across the company people are
working hard in science and engineering
to advance the fundamental understanding
and and methods that we have available
to build cars Energy Solutions robots
and anything else so can we we can do to
improve The Human Condition around the
world
it's a super exciting thing to be a part
of and it's a privilege to run a very
small piece of it in the semiconductor
group tonight we're going to talk a
little bit about dojo and give you an
update on what we've been able to do
over the last year but before we do that
I wanted to give a little bit of
background on the initial design that we
started a few years ago when we got
started the goal was to provide a
substantial Improvement to the training
latency for our autopilot team some of
the largest neural networks they trained
today run for over a month
which inhibits their ability to rapidly
explore Alternatives and evaluate them
so you know a 30X speed up would be
really nice if we could provide it at a
cost competitive and energy competitive
way
to do that we wanted to build a chip
with a lot of arithmetic arithmetic
units that we could utilize at a very
high efficiency and we spent a lot of
time studying whether we could do that
using DRM various packaging ideas all of
which failed and in the end even though
it felt like an unnatural act we decided
to reject dram as the primary storage
medium for this system and instead focus
on SRAM embedded in the chip
SRAM provides unfortunately a modest
amount of capacity but extremely high
bandwidth and very low latency and that
enables us to achieve High utilization
with the arithmetic units
those choices
of that particular choice led to a whole
bunch of other choices for example if
you want to have virtual memory you need
page tables they take up a lot of space
we didn't have space so no virtual
memory
we also don't have interrupts the
accelerator is a bare bonds Rob piece of
Hardware that's presented to a compiler
in the compiler is responsible for
scheduling everything that happens in a
terministic way so there's no need or
even desire for interrupts in the system
we also chose to pursue model
parallelism as a training methodology
which is not the typical situation most
most machines today use data parallelism
which consumes additional memory
capacity which we obviously don't have
so all of those choices led us to build
a machine that is pretty radically
different from what's available today
we also had a whole bunch of other goals
one of the most important ones was no
limits so we wanted to build a compute
fabric that would scale in an unbounded
way for the most part I mean obviously
there's physical limits now and then but
you know pretty much if your model was
too big for the computer you just had to
go buy a bigger computer that's what we
were looking for today the way package
machines are packaged there's a pretty
fixed ratio of for example GPU CPUs and
and dram capacity and network capacity
and we really wanted to disaggregate all
that so that as models evolved we could
vary the ratios of those various
elements and make the system more
flexible to meet the needs of the
autopilot team
yeah and it's so true with like No
Limits philosophy was our guiding star
all the way all of our choices were
centered around that and and to the
point that we didn't want traditional
data center infrastructure to limit our
capacity to execute these programs at
speed
so that's why we
that's why sorry about that that's why
we integrated
vertically our data center
entire data center by doing a vertical
integration of the data center
we could extract new levels of
efficiency we could optimize power
delivery Cooling
and as well as system management across
the whole data center stack rather than
doing Box by box and integrating that
those boxes into Data Centers
and to do this we also wanted to
integrate early
to figure out limits of scale uh for our
software workloads so we integrated Dojo
environment into our autopilot software
very early and we learned a lot of
lessons and today uh Bill Chang will go
over our hardware update as well as some
of the challenges that we faced along
the way and Rajiv kurian will give you a
glimpse of our compiler technology as
well as go over some of our cool results
right
there you go
thanks Pete thanks Ganesh
um I'll start tonight with a high level
vision of our system that will that will
help set the stage for the the
challenges and the problems we're
solving and then also how software will
then leverage this for performance
now our vision for Dojo is to build a
single unified accelerate a very large
one software would see a seamless
compute plane with globally addressable
very fast memory and all connected
together with uniform high bandwidth and
low latency
now to realize this we we need to use
density to achieve performance
now we leverage technology to get this
density in order to break levels of
hierarchy all the way from the chip to
the scale out systems
now silicon technology has has used this
has done this for decades chips have
followed Moore's law to for density and
integration to get performance scaling
now a key step in realizing that Vision
was our training tile
not only can we integrate 25 dies at
extremely high bandwidth but we can
scale that to any number of additional
tiles by just connecting them together
now last year we showcased our first
functional training tile and at that
time we already had workloads running on
it
and since then the team here has been
working hard and diligently to deploy
this at scale
now we've made amazing progress and had
a lot of Milestones along the way and of
course we've had a lot of unexpected
challenges
but this is where our fail fast
philosophy has allowed us to push our
boundaries
now pushing density for performance
presents all new challenges
one area is power delivery
here we need to deliver the power to our
compute die and this directly impacts
our Top Line compute performance
but we need to do this at unprecedented
density we need to be able to match our
die pitch with a power density of almost
one amp per millimeter squared
and because of the extreme integration
this needs to be a multi-tiered vertical
power solution
and because there's a complex
heterogeneous material Stack Up
we have to carefully manage the material
transition especially CTE
now why does the coefficient of thermal
expansion matter in this case
CTE is a fundamental material property
and if it's not carefully managed that
Stack Up would literally rip itself
apart
so we started this effort by working
with vendors to deliver to develop this
power solution
but we realized that we actually had to
develop this in-house
now to balance schedule and risk
we built quick iterations to support
both our system bring up and software
development
and also to find the optimal design and
stack up that would meet our final
production goals
and in the end we were able to reduce
CTE over 50 percent
and meet our performance by 3x over our
initial version
now needless to say finding this optimal
material stack up while maximizing
performance at density is extremely
difficult
now we did have unexpected challenges
along the way
here's an example where we push the
boundaries of integration that led to
component failures
this started when we scaled up to larger
and longer workloads and then
intermediate intermittently a single
site on a tile would fail
now they started out as recoverable
failures but as we pushed some much
higher and higher power these would
become permanent failures
now to understand this failure you have
to understand why and how we build our
power modules
solving density at every level is the is
is the Cornerstone of actually achieving
our system performance
now because our X Y plane is used for
high bandwidth communication
everything else must be stacked
vertically
this means all other components other
than our die must be integrated into our
power modules
now that includes our clock and our
power supplies and also our system
controllers
now in this case the failures were due
to losing clock output from our
oscillators
and after an extensive debug we found
that the root cause was due to
vibrations on the module from
piezoelectric effects our nearby
capacitors
now singing caps are not a new
phenomenon and in fact very common in
power design
but normally clock chips are placed in a
very quiet area of the board and often
not affected by power circuits but
because we needed to achieve this level
of integration these oscillators need to
be placed in very close proximity
now due to our switching frequency and
then the vibration resonance created it
caused Auto plane vibration on our mems
oscillator that caused it to crack
now the solution to this problem is a
multi-prong approach we can reduce the
vibration by using soft terminal caps
we can update our mems part with a lower
Q factor for the outer plane Direction
and we can also update our switching
frequency frequency to push the
resonance further away from these
sensitive bands
now addition to the to the density uh at
the system level we've been making a lot
of progress at the infrastructure level
we knew that we had to re-examine every
aspect of the data center infrastructure
in order to support our unprecedented
power and cooling density
we brought in a fully custom designed
CDU to support dojo's dense cooling
requirements and the amazing part is
we're able to do this at a fraction of
the cost versus buying off the shelf and
modifying it
and since our Dojo cabinet integrates
enough power and cooling to match an
entire row of standard it racks we need
to carefully design our cabinet and
infrastructure together
and we've already gone through several
iterations of this cabinet to optimize
this
and earlier in this year we started load
testing our power and cooling
infrastructure and we were able to push
it over two megawatts before we tripped
our substation and got a call from the
city
yeah
now last year we introduced only a
couple of components of our system the
custom D1 die and the training tile but
we teased the exit pod as our end goal
we'll walk through the remaining parts
of our system that are required to build
out this exit pod
now the system tray is a key part of
realizing our vision of a single
accelerator
it enables us to seamlessly seamlessly
connect tiles together not only within
the cabinet but between cabinets
we can connect these Tiles at very tight
spacing across the entire accelerator
and this is how we achieve our uniform
communication
this is a laminated bus bar that allows
us to integrate very high power
mechanical and thermal support in an
extremely dense integration
it's 75 millimeters in height and and
supports six Tiles at 135 kilograms
this is the equivalent of three to four
fully loaded high performance racks
next we need to feed data to the
training tiles this is where we've
developed the dojo interface processor
it provides our system with high
bandwidth dram to Stage our training
data
and it provides full memory bandwidth to
our training tiles using TTP our custom
protocol that we can use to communicate
across our entire accelerator
it also has high-speed ethernet that
helps us extend this custom protocol
over standard ethernet
and we provide native Hardware support
for this with little to no software
overhead
and lastly we can connect connect to it
through a standard Gen 4 pcie interface
now we pair 20 of these cards per tray
and that gives us 640 gigabytes of high
bandwidth dram
and this provides our disaggregated
memory layer for our training tiles
these cards are a high bandwidth ingest
path both through pcie and ethernet
they also provide a high ratex
z-connectivity path that allows
shortcuts across our large Dojo
accelerator
now we actually integrate the host
directly underneath our system tray
these hosts provide our ingest
processing and connect to our interface
processors through pcie
these hosts can provide Hardware video
decoder support for video Based training
and our user applications land on these
hosts that we so we can provide them
with the standard x86 Linux environment
now we can put two of these assemblies
into one cabinet and pair it with
redundant power supplies that do direct
conversion of three phase 480 volt AC
power to 52 volt DC power
Now by focusing on density at every
level
we can realize the vision of a single
accelerator
now starting with the uniform nodes on
our custom D1 die
we can connect them together in our
fully integrated training tile
and then finally seamlessly connecting
them across cabinet boundaries to form
our Dojo accelerator
and all together we can house two full
accelerators in our exit pod for a
combined one exaflop of ml compute
now all can altogether this amount of
technology and integration has only ever
been done a couple of times in the
history of compute
next we'll see how software can leverage
this to accelerate their performance
[Applause]
thanks Bill my name is Rajiv and I'm
going to talk some numbers
so our software stack begins with the pi
torch extension that speaks to our
commitment to one standard pytorch
models out of the box
we're going to talk more about our jit
compiler and the ingest pipeline that
feeds the hardware with data
abstractly performances tops times
utilization times accelerator occupancy
we've seen how the hardware provides
Peak Performance is the job of the
compiler to extract utilization from the
hardware while code is running on it
and it's the job of the ingest pipeline
to make sure that data can be fettered
at throughput high enough for the
hardware to not ever starve
so let's talk about why communication
bound models are difficult to scale
but before that let's look at why resnet
50 like models are easier to scale you
start off with a single accelerator run
the forward and backward passes followed
by the optimizer
than to scale this up you run multiple
copies of this on multiple accelerators
and while the gradient is produced by
the backward pass do need to be reduced
and this introduces some communication
this can be done Pipeline with the
backward pass
this setup scales fairly well almost
linearly
for models with much larger activations
we run into a problem as soon as we want
to run the forward pass
the batch size that fits in a single
accelerator is often smaller than the
batch Norm surface
so to get around this researchers
typically run this setup on multiple
accelerators in sync batch Norm mode
this introduces latency bound
communication to the critical path of
the forward pass and we already have a
communication bottleneck
and while there are ways to get around
this they usually involve tedious manual
work best suited for a compiler
and ultimately there's no skirting
around the fact that if your state does
not fit in a single accelerator you can
be communication bound
and even with significant efforts from
our ml Engineers we see such models
don't scale linearly
the dojo system was built to make such
models work at high utilization the high
density integration is was built to not
only accelerate the compute bound
portions of a model but also the latency
bound portions like a batch Norm or the
bandwidth bound portions like a gradient
all reduced or a parameter all gather
a slice of the dojo mesh can be carved
out to run any model
the only thing users need to do is to
make the slice large enough to fit a
bathroom surface for their particular
model
after that the partition presents itself
as one large accelerator freeing the
users from having to worry about the
internal details of execution
and as the job of the compiler to
maintain this abstraction
fine grain synchronization Primitives in
uniform low latency makes it easy to
accelerate all forms of parallelism
across integration boundaries tensors
are usually store sharded in SRAM and
replicated just in time for layers
execution we depend on the high Dojo
bandwidth to hide this replication time
tensor replication and other data
transfers are overlapped with compute
and the compiler can also recompute
layers when it's profitable to do so
we expect most models to work out of the
box as an example we took the recently
released stable diffusion model and got
it running on dojo in minutes out of the
box the Kampala was able to map it in a
model parallel manner on 25 Dojo dies
here's some pictures of a cyber truck on
Mars generated by stable diffusion
running on dojo
looks
[Applause]
looks like it still has some ways to go
before matching the Tesla Design Studio
team
so we've talked about how communication
bottlenecks can hamper scalability
perhaps an acid test of a compiler and
the underlying Hardware is executing a
cross-diabash form layer like mentioned
before this can be a Serial bottleneck
the communication phase of a bachelor
begins with nodes Computing the local
mean and standard deviations then
coordinating to reduce these values then
broadcasting these values back and then
they resume their work in parallel
so what would an ideal batch form look
like on 25 Dojo dots
let's say the previous less activations
are are already split across dice
we would expect that 350 nodes on each
die to coordinate and produce die local
mean and standard division values
ideally these would get would further
reduced with the final value ending
somewhere and towards the middle of the
tile
we would then hope to see a broadcast of
this value radiating from the center
let's see how the compiler actually
executes a real Bachelor operation
across 25 dice the communication trees
were extracted from the compiler and the
timing is from a real Hardware one we're
about to see 8750 nodes on 25 dies
coordinating to reduce and then
broadcast the bastrum mean and standard
deviation valves
dial Local reduction
followed by global reduction towards the
middle of the tie
then the reduced value broadcast
radiating from The Middle
accelerated by the Hardware's broadcast
facility
this operation takes only five
microseconds on 25 Dojo dice the same
operation takes 150 microseconds on 24
gpus this is an orders of magnitude
improvement over gpus
and while we talked about an all reduced
operation in the context of a batch Norm
it's important to reiterate that the
same advantages apply to all other
communication Primitives and these
Primitives are essential for large scale
training
so how about full model performance
so while we think that resonant 50 is
not a good representation of real world
Tesla workloads it is a standard
Benchmark so let's start there
we are already able to match the 100 die
for die however perhaps a hint of dojo's
capabilities is that we're able to hit
this number with just a batch of 8 per
die
but Dojo was really built to tackle
larger complex models
so when we set out to tackle real world
workloads we looked at the usage
patterns of our current GPU cluster and
two models stood up the auto labeling
networks a class of offline models that
are used to generate ground truth and
the occupancy networks that you heard
about
the auto labeling networks are large
models that have high arithmetic
intensity while the occupancy networks
can be in justbound we chose these
models because together they account for
a large chunk of our current GPU cluster
usage and they would challenge the
system in different ways
so how do we do on these two networks
the results we're about to see were
measured on multi-die systems for both
the GPU and Dojo but normalized to per
die numbers
on our Auto labeling Network we're
already able to surpass the performance
of an a100 with our current Hardware
running on our older generation vrms on
our production Hardware with our newer
vrams that translates to doubling the
throughput of an a100
and our model showed that with some key
compiler optimizations we could get to
more than three extra performance of an
a100
we see even bigger leaps on the
occupancy Network
almost 3x with our production Hardware
with room for more
foreign
[Applause]
level of compiler performance we could
replace the ml compute of
one two three four five and six GPU
boxes with just a single Dojo tile
[Applause]
and this Dojo tile costs less than one
of these GPU boxes
whoa
yeah
what it really means is that networks
that took more than a month to train now
take less than a week
alas when we measure things it did not
turn out so well
at the pie torch level we did not see
our expected performance out of the git
and this timeline chart shows our
problem
the teeny tiny little green bars that's
the compile code running on the
accelerator
the row is mostly white space where the
hardware is just waiting for data
with our dense ml compute Dojo hosts
effectively have 10x more ml compute
than the GPU host the data loader is
running on this one host simply couldn't
keep up with all that ml Hardware
so to solve our data loader scalability
issues we knew we had to get over the
limit of this single host
the Tesla transport protocol moves data
seamlessly across host tiles and ingest
processors so we extended the Tesla
transport protocol to work over ethernet
we then built the dojo network interface
called the dnic to leverage TTP over
ethernet this allows any host with a
dnic card to be able to DM it to and
from other TTP endpoints
so we started with the dojo mesh
then we added a tier of data loading
hosts equipped with the dnic card
we connected these hosts to the mesh via
an ethernet switch now every host in
this data loading tier is capable of
reaching all TTP endpoints in the dojo
mesh via Hardware accelerated dma
after these optimizations went in our
occupancy went from four percent
to 97 percent
so the data loading sections have
reduced
data the data loading sections have
reduced drastically and the ml Hardware
is kept busy we actually expect this
number to go to 100 pretty soon
after these changes went in we saw the
full expected speed up from the pytorch
layer and we were back in business
so we started with Hardware design that
breaks through traditional integration
boundaries in service of our vision of a
single giant accelerator
we've seen how the compiler and just
layers build on top of that Hardware
so after proving your performance on
these complex real-world networks we
knew what our first large-scale
deployment would Target our high
arithmetic intensity Auto labeling
Networks
today that occupies 4000 gpus over 72
GPU racks
with our dense computer and our high
performance we expect to provide the
same throughput with just four Dojo
cabinets
[Applause]
and these four Dojo cabinets will be
part of our first exopod that we plan to
build by quarter one of 2023
this one more than double Tesla's Auto
labeling capacity
[Applause]
the first extra part is part of a total
of seven extra parts that we plan to
build in Palo Alto right here across the
wall
[Applause]
and we have a display cabinet from one
of these exopods for everyone to look at
six tiles densely packed on a tray 54
petaflops of compute 640 gigabytes of
high bandwidth memory with power and
host to feed it
a lot of
and we're building out new versions of
all our cluster components and
constantly improving our software to hit
new limits of skill we believe that we
can get another 10x improvement with our
next Generation Hardware
and to realize their ambitious goals we
need the best software and Hardware
Engineers so please come talk to us or
visit tesla.com AI thank you
[Applause]
all right all right let me know
all right
so we
um hopefully that was enough detail
and now we can move to questions
um and uh guys uh like I think the team
came back come out on stage and but
we really wanted to show the the depth
and breadth of Tesla in um artificial
intelligence
compute Hardware
robotics actuators and
[Music]
and try to really shift the perception
of the company away from uh you know a
lot of people think we're like just a
car company or we make cool cars
whatever but uh
they don't have most people have no idea
that Tesla is arguably the the leader in
real world AI hardware and software
and that we're building
uh what is arguably the first
uh some of the most radical
computer architecture since the the
crayon supercomputer
and I think if you're interested in
developing uh some some of the most
advanced technology in the world that's
going to really affect the world in a
positive way uh tells us the place to be
so yeah let's fire away with some
questions
I think there's a mic at the front and a
mic at the back
uh
thank you very much I I was impressed
here
yeah I was impressed very much by
Optimus but I wonder why they don't
driven the hunt why did you choose a
tender driven approach for the hunt
because tendons are not very durable and
why spring loaded
well this is pretty cool awesome yes
that's a great question
um you know when it comes to any type of
actuation scheme there's trade-offs
between you know whether or not it's a
tendon urine system or some type of
linkage based system I'm just keep in
mind close to your mouth a little bit
closer yeah Jeremy cool
um so yeah the main reason why we went
for a tendon-based system is that you
know first we actually investigated some
synthetic tendons but we found that
metallic boating cables are you know a
lot stronger
um one of the advantages of these cables
um is that it's very good for part
reduction we do want to make a lot of
these hands so having a bunch of parts a
bunch of small linkages ends up being
you know a problem when you're making a
lot of something one of the big reasons
that you know
tendons are better than linkages in a
sense is that you can be anti-backlash
so anti-backlash essentially you know
allows you to not have any gaps or you
know stuttery Motion in your fingers
spring-loaded mainly what spring loaded
allows us to do is it allows us to have
active opening so instead of having to
have two actuators to drive the fingers
closed and then open we have the ability
to you know have the tendon drive them
closed and then the Springs passively
extend and this is something that's seen
in our hands as well right we have the
ability to actively flex and then we
also have the ability to extend yeah
I mean our goal with Optimus is to have
a robot that is maximally useful as
quickly as possible so there's a lot of
ways to solve the various problems of a
humanoid robot
um and uh we're probably not balking up
the right Tree on on all the Technical
Solutions and I should say that we're
we're open to evolving the Technical
Solutions that you see here over time
we're not they're not locked in stone
um but we do we have to pick something
um in and we want to pick something
that's going to allow us to
produce the robot as quickly as possible
and have it like I said be useful as
quickly as possible we're trying to
follow the goal of fastest path to a
useful robot that can be made at volume
and we're going to test the robot
internally at Tesla uh in in our Factory
and uh and just see like how useful is
it because you have to have a you're
going to close the loop on reality to
confirm that the robot is in fact useful
um and uh yeah so we're just gonna use
it to build things and um we're
confident we can do that with the hand
that we have currently designed but this
I'm for sure they'll be had version two
version three and we may change the
architecture quite significantly over
time
sorry Hi
um you're the Optimus robot is really
impressive that you did a great job
um bipedal robots are really difficult
um but what I noticed might be missing
from your plan is uh to acknowledge the
utility of the human spirit and I'm
wondering if Optimus will ever get a
personality and be able to laugh at our
jokes while they've well it folds our
clothes
yeah absolutely
um I think we want to have
really fun versions of Optimus
um and so that optimists can both do be
utilitarian and do tasks but can also be
kind of like a friend
um and a buddy and and um hang out with
you
and I'm sure people will think of all
sorts of creative uses for this robot
um
and uh you know the thing once you have
the core intelligence and actuators
figured out then you can actually
you know put all sorts of
costumes I guess
on on the robot I mean you can make the
robot look uh
you can scan the robot in many different
ways
um and um I'm sure people will find uh
very interesting ways to to uh
yeah versions of Optimus so
thanks for the great presentation I
wanted to know if there was an
equivalent to interventions in Optimus
it seems like labeling through moments
where humans disagree with what's going
on is important and in a humanoid robot
that might be also a desirable source of
information
yes it was saying
um
yeah I I think we uh we'll have ways to
remote operate the robot and intervene
when it does something bad especially
when we are training the robot and
bringing it up
um and hopefully we you know design it
in a way that we can stop the robot from
if it's going to hit something we can
just like hold it and it'll stop it
won't like you know crush your hand or
something and those are all intervention
data uh
yeah and we can learn a lot from our
simulation systems too where we can
check for collisions and supervise that
those are bad actions
yeah I mean so Optimus we want over time
to for it to be
um you know an Android kind of Android
that you'd seen in in Sci-Fi movies like
Star Trek the Next Generation like data
but obviously we could program the robot
to be less robot-like and more friendly
and and uh
you know you can obviously learn to
emulate humans and and feel very natural
so as as AI in general improves uh we
can uh add that to the robot and
um you know it should be obviously able
to do simple instructions uh or even
into it what it is that you want
um so you could give it a high level uh
instruction and then it can break that
down into a series of actions and and
take those actions
hi uh yeah it's exciting to think that
with the Optimus you will uh think that
you can achieve orders of magnitude of
improvement and economic output
um that's really exciting
um and when Tesla started the mission
was to accelerate the Advent of
renewable energy or sustainable
transport so with the Optimus do you
still see that mission being this
mission statement of Tesla or is it
going to be updated with you know
mission to accelerate the Advent of I
don't know infinite abundance or
Limitless Limitless economy
yeah it I mean it is not strictly
speaking
um Optimus is not strictly speaking uh
directly in line with uh accelerating
sustainable energy
it you know
to the degree that it is more efficient
at getting things done than a person it
does I guess help with if you know
sustainable energy but it I think the
mission effectively does does somewhat
broaden with the Advent of Optimus uh to
uh you know I don't know making the
future awesome so you know I think you
look at optimists and um I know about
you but I I'm excited to see what
optimists will become
and you know this is like
you know if you could I mean you can
tell like any given technology
if are you do you want to see what it's
like in a year two years three years
four years five years ten
I'd say for sure you definitely want to
see what what's happened with Optimus
um whereas you know a bunch of other
Technologies are you know sort of
plateaued
um
about name names here but uh
[Laughter]
um you know so
I think Optimus is going to be
incredible in like five years ten years
like mind-blowing and I'm really
interested to see that happen I hope you
are too
oh I think
um I have a quick question here I'm
Justin and I was wondering like are you
planning to extend like conversational
capabilities for the robot and my second
follow-up question to that is what's
like the end goal what's the end goal
with Optimus
uh yeah optimists would definitely have
conversational capabilities so
um
I I you'd be able to talk to it and have
a conversation and it would feel quite
natural
so from an end call standpoint I'm I'm
I don't know I think it's Gonna Keep
keep evolving and
I'm not sure where where it ends up but
some some place interesting for sure
um
you know we always have to be careful
about the you know don't go down the
Terminator path uh that's a you know I I
thought for maybe we should start off
with a video of like the Terminator
starting off with this you know skull
crushing but oh that might be I don't
know if you want to take that too
seriously so
yeah you know we we do want Optimus to
be safe so we are uh designing in
um safeguards where you can uh locally
stop the robot
um
and uh
you know with like basically a localized
control ROM that you can't update over
the Internet which I think that's quite
important
um
essential frankly
um so
uh like a localized stop button
um
remote remote control something like
that
that cannot be changed
um
but I mean it's definitely going to be
interesting
it won't be boring
so
okay yeah I see you today you have very
attractive product with dojo and its
applications so I'm wondering what's the
future for Dojo platform we would like
to provide like a infrastructure
infrastructure and service like AWS or
you'll be like a sales a chip like the
Nvidia so basically what's the future
because of the I say you use a seven
nanometer so they developer cost is like
easily over 10 million US Dollars how do
you make the penis like a business-wise
yeah I mean
um Dojo is is a is a very big computer
um and actually we'll be use a lot of
power and needs a lot of cooling so I
think it's probably going to make more
sense to have Dojo operate in like uh
Amazon web services manner than to try
to sell it to someone else
um so the the most that would be the
most efficient way to operate Dojo is
just have it be uh a a service that you
can use uh that's available online and
that where you can train your models way
faster and for less money
and that as the
um world transitions to software 2.0
and that's on the bingo card
someone I know it has to know how to
drink five tequilas
um so let's see
um
software 2.0
[Laughter]
yeah we'll use a lot of neural net
training
so
uh you know it kind of makes sense that
over time as there's more more neural
net stuff that people will want to use
and uh the fastest lowest cost neural
net training system
so I think there's a lot of opportunity
in that direction
hi my name is Ali jahanian thank you for
this event it is very inspirational my
question is
um I'm wondering what is your vision for
uh
humanit robots that understand our
emotions and art and can contribute to
our creativity
well I think there's this um you're
already seeing robots that at least uh
are able to generate very interesting
art with like like Dali
um and Dali 2. um
and I think we'll we'll start seeing
AI that can actually generate even
movies that have a that have coherence
like interesting movies and tell jokes
so it's quite remarkable how fast AI is
uh advancing
um
at many companies besides Tesla
we're headed for a very interesting
future
and um yeah so
you guys want to comment on that yeah I
guess uh The Optimist robot can come up
with physical art not just digital art
you can you know you can ask for some
dance moves in text or voice and then
you can produce those in the future so
it's a lot of like physical heart not
just digital art
oh yeah yeah computers can absolutely
make a physical art yeah yeah 100 yeah
like dance sure play soccer or whatever
you
um I mean it needs to get more agile but
over time for sure
thanks so much for the presentation for
the Tesla autopilot slides I noticed
that the models that you were using were
heavily motivated by language models and
I was wondering what the history of that
was and how much of an improvement it
gave I thought that that was a really
interesting curious choice to use
language models for the lane
transitioning
so there are sort of two aspects for why
we transitioned to language modeling so
the first talk talk loud and close Okay
okay got it
yeah so the language models help us in
two ways the first way is that it lets
us predict lanes that we couldn't have
otherwise as a shook mentioned earlier
basically when we predicted Lanes in
sort of a dense 3D fashion you can only
model certain kinds of lanes but we want
to get those crisscrossing connections
inside of intersections it's just not
possible to do that without making it a
graph prediction if you try to do this
with dense segmentation it just doesn't
work
um
also the lane prediction is a multimodal
problem sometimes you just don't have
sufficient visual information to know
precisely how things look on the other
side of the intersection so you need a
method that can generalize and produce
um you know coherent predictions you
don't want to be predicting two lanes in
three lanes at the same time you want to
commit to one in a generative model like
these language models provides that
hi oh hi uh my name is Giovanni
um yeah thanks for the presentation
that's really nice I have a question for
our FSD team
so for the neural networks how do you
test like how do you do unit test
software unit tests on that like do you
have like a a bunch or I don't know mid
thousands or
uh yes uh cases where
so the neural network that after you
train it you have to pass it before you
release it to as a product right uh yeah
what's your software unit testing
strategies for this basically yeah glad
you asked there's like a series of tests
that we have defined uh starting from
you know unit test for the software
itself but then for the neural network
models we have VIP sets defined where
you know you can Define uh if you just
have a large test set that's not enough
what we find uh we need like
sophisticated uh VIP sets for different
failure modes and then we curate them
and grow them over the time of the
product so over the years we have like
like hundreds of thousands of examples
where we have been failing in the past
that we have curated and so we for any
new model we test against the entire
history of these failures uh and then
keep adding to this test set
on top of this we have Shadow modes
where we ship these models in silent to
the car and we get data back on where
they are failing or succeeding uh and
there's extensive QA program it's very
hard to ship a regression there's like
nine levels of filters before it hits
customers but then we have really good
infra to make this all efficient
and I'm one of the QA testers so I QA
the car yeah like a Creator yeah so I'm
constantly in the car just being
queuing like whatever the latest uh
alpha build is that doesn't totally
crash
finds a lot of bugs
uh hi um great event I have a question
about uh foundational models for uh I
have all seen that uh big models that
really can when you scale up with data
and model parameter right from GT3 to
Palm it can actually now do reasoning do
you see that it's essential uh skinning
up foundational models with data and
size and then at least you can get a
teacher model right that potentially can
solve all the problems and then you
distill to a student model is that how
you see foundational models relevant for
at 100 I mean that's quite similar to
our Auto labeling model so we we don't
just have models that run in the car we
train models that are entirely Offline
that are like extremely large that can't
run in real time on the car so we just
run those offline on the servers
producing really good labels
that can then train the online networks
so that's one form of distillation of
these teacher student models
right in terms of foundation models we
are building some really really large
data sets that you know are multiple
petabytes and we are seeing that some of
these tasks work really well uh when we
have this large data sets like the
kinematics like I mentioned video in all
the kinematics out of all the objects
and up to the fourth derivative and
people thought we couldn't do detection
with cameras detection depth velocity
acceleration and imagine how precise
these have to be for these higher order
derivatives to be accurate and this all
comes from these kind of large data sets
and large models
so we are seeing the equivalent of
foundation models in our own way for
geometry and kinematics and things like
those
you want to add anything John
yeah I'll keep it brief basically
whenever we train on a larger data set
we see big okay basically whenever we
train on a larger data set we see big
improvements in our model performance
and basically whenever we initialize our
networks with you know some pre-training
step from some other auxiliary task we
basically see improvements the
self-supervised or supervised with large
data sets both help a lot
hey so at the beginning Elon said that
Tesla was potentially interested in
building artificial general intelligence
systems given the potentially
transformative impact of technology like
that it seems prudent to invest in
technical AGI safety uh expertise
specifically I know Tesla does a lot of
technical narrow AI Safety Research I
was curious if Tesla was intending to
try to build expertise in technical
artificial general intelligence safety
specifically
well if I mean if if it starts looking
like we're gonna be uh making a
significant contribution to artificial
general intelligence then then we'll for
sure invest in in uh safety I'm a big
believer in AI safety I think there
should be an AI uh
sort of regulatory Authority at the
government level uh just as there is a
regulatory Authority for uh anything
that affects Public Safety so we have a
regulatory Authority for aircraft and
cars and uh sort of food and drugs and
because they affect Public Safety and AI
also affects Public Safety so I think
um and this is not really something that
government I think understands yet but I
think I think there should be a referee
that is uh ensuring
um or doing trying to ensure uh Public
Safety for uh AGI
um
and you think of like well like what are
the elements that are necessary to to
create AGI like uh
the accessible data set is extremely
important and if you've got a large
number of of cars and humanoid robots uh
processing
you know petabytes of of video data and
audio data from The Real World uh just
like humans that that's that might be
the biggest data set it probably is the
biggest data set
um
because in addition to that you can
obviously incrementally scan the the
internet
um
but what the internet can't quite do is
is have
millions or hundreds of millions of
cameras in the real world
like I said with audio and and uh and
other sensors as well so so I think we
probably will have the most amount of
data
um and probably the most amount of TR of
training power
therefore probably uh we will make a
contribution to AGI
hey um I noticed the semi was back there
but we haven't talked about it too much
I was just wondering for the semi truck
what are the uh changes you're thinking
about from a sensing perspective I
imagine there's very different
requirements obviously than just a car
if and if you don't think that's true
why is that true
uh no I think uh basically uh you can
drive a car I mean think about what
drives any vehicle it's um a biological
neural net uh with uh with eyes with
cameras essentially so if um and really
what is your your primary sensors are uh
two uh cameras on a slow gimbal a very
slow gimbal
um that's uh that's your head uh so if
if um you know if a biological neural
net with with two cameras on a slow
gimbal can drive a semi truck then
um if you've got like eight cameras with
continuous 360 degree Vision uh
operating at a higher frame rate and
much higher reaction rate then I think
it is obvious that you should be able to
drive a semi or any any vehicle much
better than a human
hi my name is Akshay thank you for the
event uh assuming you know Optimus would
be used for different use cases and
would evolve at different piece for
these use cases uh would it be possible
to sort of develop and deploy different
software and Hardware components
independently and deploy them you know
in the
in Optimus so that the overall you know
feature development is faster for
Optimus
reference to the questions
okay all right we did not comprehend uh
unfortunately our neural net did not
comprehend the question
uh
yeah so well next question
I want to switch a gear to the autopilot
so
um when you guys plan to roll out the
FSD beta to countries other than us and
Canada and also my next question is
what's the biggest bottleneck or the
technological barrier you think in the
current order part of the stack and how
you envision to solve that to make the
autopilot is considerable better than
human in terms of a performance Matrix
safety assurance and the human
confidence
I think you're also matching 4V uh fstb
or whatever you are guys going to
combine the highway and the city as a
single stack and some architectural uh
big Improvement can you maybe experiment
a bit on that thank you
uh well that's a whole bunch of
questions well we we
I we're hopeful to be able to I think
from a technical standpoint
um FSD beta should be it should be
possible to roll that sfsd beta uh
worldwide by the end of this year
um
um but we you know from for a lot of
countries we need regulatory approval
um and so we are somewhat gated by the
regulatory approval in other countries
um
but I you know I but I think from
technical standpoint it will be ready to
go
uh to to a worldwide beta by the end of
this year and there's quite a big
Improvement that we're expecting to
release next month uh that will always
be especially good at uh
assessing the velocity of fast-moving
cross traffic and a bunch of other
things so anyone elaborate
for the objects
yeah I guess so there used to be a lot
of differences between production
autopilot and the full self-driving beta
but those differences have been getting
smaller and smaller over time I think
just a few months ago we now use the
same vision only object detection stack
in both FSD and in the production
autopilot on all vehicles
um there's still a few differences the
primary one being the way that we
predict Lanes right now so we upgraded
the modeling of Lane so that it could
handle these more complex geometries
like I mentioned in the talk in
production autopilot we still use a
simpler lane model but we're extending
our current FSD beta models to work in
all sort of Highway scenarios as well
uh yeah and the the version of uh FST
beta that I drive actually does have the
integrated stack so this uh it uses the
FSD stack uh both in city streets and
Highway and uh it works quite well for
me uh we but we need to validate it in
all kinds of weather like heavy rain
snow dust
um and uh and just make sure it's
working uh as better than the production
stack uh in you know across a wide range
of uh environments but we're pretty
close to that
um
I mean I think it's I don't know maybe
I'll definitely be before the end of the
year and and maybe November
Yeah in our personal drives uh the FSD
stack on Highway drives already way
better than the production stack we have
and we do expect to also include the
parking lot stack as a part of the FSC
stack before the end of this year
so that will basically bring us to you
sit in the car in the parking lot and
drive till the end of the parking lot at
a parking spot before the end of this
year
yeah and and in terms of the like the
the fundamental the fundamental metric
to optimize against is
um how many miles per between a
necessary intervention
so
um just massively improving the how many
miles the car can drive on in full
autonomy before an intervention is
required that is uh safety critical
um so
yeah that's uh that's the fundamental
metric that we're measuring uh every
week and we're making radical
improvements on that
hi thank you hi thank you so much for
the presentation very inspiring my name
is Daisy I actually have a non-technical
question for you I'm curious uh if you
are back to your 20s what are some of
the things you wish you knew back then
what are some advice you would give to
your younger self
well I'm trying to figure out something
useful
uh to say
yeah yeah I joined Tesla would be one
thing
um
um yeah I think just generally try to
um
expose yourself to as many smart people
as possible
and I read a lot of books
um
you know I do that did do that though uh
so
um
I think there's some Merit to just also
uh like not being like necessarily too
intense uh and and like enjoying the
moment a bit more I would say to 20 or
20 something me uh just to you know uh
stop and smell the roses occasionally
would probably be a good idea
um
you know it's like when we're developing
the the Falcon one rocket
and uh on on the quadriline atoll and we
had this beautiful little island that
we're developing the rocket on
and not once that during that entire
time did I even have a drink on the
beach I'm like well I should have had a
drink on the beach that would have been
fine
thank you very much uh I think you have
excited all of the robotics people with
with Optimus uh this feels very much
like 10 years ago in driving but as uh
driving has proved to be harder than it
actually looked 10 years ago what do we
know now that we didn't 10 years ago
that would make for example AGI on a
humanoid come faster
well I mean it it seems to me that HEI
is advancing very quickly
um
hardly a week goes by without some
significant announcement
and uh yeah I mean
at this point like AI seems to be able
to win at almost any rule-based game
uh it's it's able to create extremely
impressive art
um
engage in conversations that
are are very sophisticated you know
write essays
and these these just keep improving
um
and there's there's so much more
so so many more talented people working
on AI
and the hardware is getting better I
think it's a it's a AI is on a super
like a strong exponential curve of of
improvement independent of what we do at
Tesla
um and obviously we'll benefit somewhat
from that exponential curve of
improvement with AI
um
accessible just also happens to be very
good at actuators that Motors you know
Motors gearboxes controllers Power
Electronics batteries
um sensors
and um
you know really like I say that you know
the biggest difference between the robot
on four wheels and the robot with arms
and legs is is getting the actuators
right actually it's an actuators and
sensors problem
um
and obviously the you know how you
control those actuators and sensors but
it's a
yeah actuators and sensors and how you
control the actuators it's a
I know where you have to have like the
ingredients necessary to create a
compelling robot and we're doing it so
hi Elan uh
you are actually bringing the humanity
to the next level literally Tesla and
you are bringing the humanity to the
next level so you said Optimus Prime uh
Optimus will be used in next Tesla
Factory my question is will a new Tesla
Factory will be fully run by Optimus
program
and
and when can general public order a
humanoid
yeah I think it'll it'll you know we're
going to start optimists with very
simple tasks in the factory
um
you know like maybe just like loading
apart like you saw in the video loading
a part uh
for you know carrying apart from one
place to another or loading a part into
um a one of our more conventional robot
cells uh to you know uh that welds the
body together so we'll start you know
just trying to how do we make it useful
at all
um and then and then gradually expand
the number of situations where it's
useful
um and I think that that
the number of situations where Optimus
is useful will it will grow
exponentially
um like really really fast
um in terms of when people can order one
I don't know I think it's not that far
away
um well I think you mean when can people
receive one
um so
I don't know I'm like I'd say
probably within three years I'm not more
than five years within three to five
years you could probably receive an
Optimus
I feel the best way to make the progress
for agis to involve as many smart people
across the world as possible and given
the size and resource of Tesla compared
to robot companies and given the state
of humanity research at the moment
wouldn't make sense for the kind of
Tesla to sort of Open Source some of the
simulation hardware parts I think Tesla
can still be the dominant platformer
where it can be something like Android
OS or like iOS stuff for the entire
human or research would that be
something that rather than keeping the
Optimus to just Tesla researchers or the
factory itself can open it and let the
whole world explore human research
um I think we have to be careful about
Optimus being potentially uh used uh in
ways that are bad uh because that is one
of the possible things to do so
I think we would you know would
provide optimists
where you can provide instructions to
optimists but where those instructions
are uh you know governed by some laws of
robotics
um that you cannot overcome
so
you know not doing harm to others and
uh
it would have I think probably quite a
few safety related things with with
Optimus yeah so all right well we'll
just take maybe a few more questions and
then and then and then thank you all for
coming
questions
um
one deep and one Broad
on the Deep for Optimus what's the
current and what's the ideal controller
bandwidth and then in the broader
question uh there's this big
advertisement for the depth and breadth
of the company what is it uniquely about
Tesla that enables that
uh anyone want to tackle the bandwidth
question yeah
yeah so the technical bandwidth of the
costume
okay
for the bandwidth question you have to
understand or or figure out what is the
task that you wanted to do and what is
the free if you took a frequency
transform of that task what is it that
you want your limbs to do and that's
where you get your bandwidth from it's
not a number that you can specifically
just say you need to understand your use
case and that's from that's where the
bandwidth comes from uh okay what is the
broad question
I don't quite remember the breadth and
depth thing I can answer the breadth and
depth but yeah
I was interesting on the back of the
question I think we probably will just
end up increasing the bandwidth or you
know which translates to the effect of
uh dexterity
um and reaction time of the of the robot
um like you could save states it's not
one Hertz
um and it's maybe you don't need to go
all the way to 100 Hertz uh but I don't
know maybe 10 25 I don't know
over time I think the the bandwidth will
will increase quite a bit uh or or
translated to uh dexterity and latency
um uh you'd want to minimize that over
time uh yeah
minimize latency maximize dexterity
um
I mean in terms of breadth and depth um
I I guess you know we've got
we're a pretty big company at this point
so we've got a lot of different areas of
expertise that we necessarily have to
develop in order to make autonomous or
in order to make electric cars and then
in order to make autonomous electric
cars
um we've we've just I mean Tesla is like
a whole series of startups basically and
um so far they've
um almost all been quite successful
um so we must be doing something right
um and I you know I consider one of my
uh core responsibilities uh Iranian
company is to have an environment where
uh great Engineers can flourish
and and I think in a lot of companies
I don't know maybe most companies uh if
if somebody's a really talented driven
engineer they they're unable to actually
uh
their their talents are are suppressed
at a lot of companies and it's you know
and and some of the companies that the
engineering Talent is suppressed in a
way that is uh maybe not obviously bad
but but where it's just so comfortable
and you paid so much money and you but
you your the output you actually have to
produce is so low that it's like a Honey
Trap you know so like there's a few
Honey Trap uh places in Silicon Valley
uh where they're not necessarily don't
seem like bad places for engineers but
you have say like a good engineer went
in and what did they get out
and the output of of that engineering
Talent it seems very low
even though there seem to be enjoying
themselves uh that's why I call it
there's a few Honey Trap companies in
Silicon Valley uh Tesla is not a Honey
Trap we're demanding and it's like
you're gonna get a lot of [ __ ] done
um and it's going to be really cool
um
and it's you know not going to be easy
but uh if you are a super talented
engineer your talents will be uh used I
think to a greater degree than anywhere
else
you know
SpaceX also that way so
Highline uh uh I have two questions so
both to the autopilot team so the thing
is like uh I have been following your
progress for the past few years so today
you have made changes on like the lean
detection like you said that like
previously you are doing instant
semantic segmentation now you guys are
built transfer models for like building
the lanes so what are another some some
other common challenges which you guys
are facing right now like which you are
solving in future as a curious engineer
so that like we as a researcher can work
on those start working on those and the
second question is like I'm really
curious about the data engine like you
guys have like told a case like where
the car is stopped so how are you
finding cases which is very much similar
to that from the data which you have
like so little bit more on the data
engine would be great so that's it okay
um I'll start answer the first question
uh using occupancy Network as an example
so uh what you saw in the presentation
did not exist a year ago so we only
spent one year about time I'm
relationship with more than 12 occupancy
Network and you have a one Foundation
model actually to represent the entire
physical world around everywhere and you
always the condition is actually really
really challenging so
only over a year ago we're kind of like
driving a 2d where if there's a war and
it says curve we kind of represent with
the same static Edge which is obviously
you know not not ideal right there's a
big difference between a curve and a
wall when you drive you make different
choices right so after we realize that
we have to go to 3D we have to basically
re-sync the entire problem and think
about how we address that so this will
be like one example of challenges we
have uh uh we have a conquer in the past
year
yeah to answer the question about how we
actually source examples of the tricky
stopped cars there's a few ways to go
about this but two examples are one we
can trigger for disagreements within our
signals so let's say that parked bit
flickers between parked and driving will
trigger that back and the second is we
can leverage more of the Shadow mode
logic so if the customer ignores the car
but we think we should stop for it we'll
get that data back too so these are just
different like various trigger logic
that allows us to get those data
campaigns back
hi
uh thank you for the amazing
presentation thanks so much uh so there
are a lot of companies that are focusing
on the AGI problem and one of the
reasons why it's such a hard problem is
because the problem itself is so hard to
Define several companies have several
different definitions they focus on
different things so what is Tesla how is
Tesla defining the ATI problem and what
are you focusing on specifically
well well we're not actually
specifically focused on AGI I'm simply
saying that HGI is so is seems likely to
be an emergent property of of what we're
doing
um
because we're creating all these
autonomous cars and autonomous humanoids
um that are actually uh within a truly
gigantic data stream that's coming in
and and being processed
um it's by far the most amount of real
world data and and data you can't get by
just searching the internet because you
have to be out there in the world and
interacting with people and interacting
with the of the roads and and just you
know Earth is a big place and reality is
messy and complicated
um so so I think it's sort of like uh
likely to just it just seems likely to
be an emergent property of if you've got
you know tens or hundreds of millions of
autonomous vehicles and and maybe even a
comparable number of humanoids uh maybe
more than that on the humanoid front
um well that's just the most amount of
data
um and if that that video is being
processed
it just seems likely that
you know the the cars will will
definitely get way better than human
drivers and the the humanoid robots will
become
increasingly
indistinguishable from humans perhaps
and and so then like you said you have a
emergent property of of AGI
um
and arguably the you know humans
collectively are sort of a super
intelligence as well especially as we
improve the data rate between humans I
mean think like that seems to be way
back in the early days the internet was
like the internet was like
um Humanity acquiring a nervous system
where now all of a sudden any one
element of humanity could know uh all of
the knowledge of of humans by connecting
to the internet almost all the knowledge
or certainly huge part of it whereas
previously uh we would exchange
information by osmosis by you know by
we'd have to like in order to transfer
data so you would have to write a letter
someone would have to carry the letter
by person to another person and then a
whole bunch of things in between and
then it was like
this position yeah I mean
it's insanely slow when you think about
it
um and even if you were in the Library
of Congress you still didn't have access
to all the world's information and you
certainly couldn't search it
and I know obviously very few people are
in the Library of Congress so
um
I mean one of the great
um
a sort of equality elements
like the internet is has been the most
the biggest equalizer in history in
terms of access to information or
knowledge
um in any student of History I think
would agree with this
because you know you go back a thousand
years there were very few books like
like and books would be incredibly
expensive but only a few people knew how
to read and only if an even smaller
number of people even had a book
now now look at it like you you can
access any book instantly you can learn
anything for basically for free
it's pretty incredible
so
you know I was asked uh recently
what
period of History would I prefer to be
at the most
and my answer was right now
this is the most interesting time in
history and I read a lot of history
so let's oh yeah let's do our best to
keep that going
yeah
and to go back to one of the early
questions I would answer like you can
the the thing that's happened over time
with respect to Tesla autopilot is that
we've just the
the neural Nets have gotten
have gradually absorbed more and more
software and in the limit of course you
could say simply take the videos as seen
by the car uh and compare those to these
the steering inputs from the steering
wheel and pedals which are very simple
inputs uh and it in principle you could
train with nothing in between because
that's what humans are doing with a
biological neural net you could train
based on video and uh and and what
trains the video is the the moving of
the the steering wheel and the pedals
with no other software in between
we're not there yet but it's gradually
going in that direction
oh all right wait last question
are you going uh I think we've got a
question in the front here uh hello
there right there I will do two
questions fine over there
um hi uh thanks for such a great
presentation well the old question last
um with FSD being used by so many people
uh do you think what's the com how do
you evaluate the company's risk
tolerance in terms of performance
statistics and do you think there needs
to be more transparency or regulation
from third parties as to how what's good
enough and
um defining like
thresholds for performance uh across
some many miles
uh sure well the you know I
the the number one design uh requirement
at Tesla is safety so um like and that
goes across the board so in terms of the
mechanical safety of the car we have the
lowest probability of injury of any cars
ever tested by the government for just a
passive mechanical safety essentially
crash structure and airbags and whatnot
um
uh we have the best uh uh the highest
rating for active safety as well
and um
I think it's going to get to the point
where you the act of safety is so
ridiculously good it's it's it's it's
like just absurdly better than a human
um and then with respect to uh autopilot
um we do publish this uh broadly
speaking the statistics on
um miles driven with cars that have no
autonomy or Tesla cars with no autonomy
with kind of a hardware one Hardware two
Hardware three
um and then uh the ones that are in FSD
beta
um and we see steady improvements all
along the way
um and you know sometimes there's this
dichotomy of you know should you uh wait
until the car is like I don't know uh
three times safer than a person before
deploying any technology but I think
that's that's actually morally wrong
um at the point of which you believe
that that adding autonomy uh reduces uh
injury and death
um
I think you have a moral obligation to
deploy it uh even though you're going to
get sued and blamed by a lot of people
because the people whose lives you've
saved don't know that their lives are
saved and the people the people who who
do occasionally die or get injured they
definitely know or their estate does uh
that it was you know whatever there's a
problem with with autopilot
um that's why you have to look at the at
the numbers in sort of total miles
driven how many accidents occurred how
many accidents were serious how many
fatalities and you know we've got well
over three million cars on the road so
this it's that's a lot of miles driven
every day it's not going to be perfect
but what matters it is that is that it
is very clearly safer uh than not
deploying it
um
yeah so I think uh last question
I think yeah so thanks what's the last
question here
okay
um yeah I got it okay uh hi so
um I do not work on Hardware so maybe
the hardware team and you guys can
enlighten me uh why is it required that
there be symmetry
um in the design of Optimus because
humans uh we have handedness right we
are we use some set of muscles more than
others over time there is wear and tear
uh right so maybe you'll start to see
some joint failures or some actuator
failures more over time I understand
that this is extremely pre-stage
um also we as humans have based so much
fantasy and fiction over super human
capabilities like all of us don't want
to walk right over there we want to
extend our arms and like we have all
these you know a lot of fantasy
Fantastical designs so considering
everything else that is going on in
terms of batteries and intensity of
compute maybe you can leverage all those
aspects into coming up with something
well I don't know more interesting in
terms of your the robot that you're
building and I'm hoping uh you're able
to explore those directions
yeah I mean I think it would be cool to
have like you know make Inspector Gadget
real that would be pretty sweet
um so yeah I mean you know right now we
just want to make a basic humanoid what
work well and our goal is fastest path
to a useful uh humanoid robot I think
this is this will ground Us in reality
literally
um and ensure that we are uh doing
something useful like one of the hardest
things to do is to be useful uh to to
actually and then and then to have high
utility under the curve like how many
people did you help time you know and
how much help did you
you provide to each person on average
and then how many people did you help
the total utility uh like trying to
actually ship useful product
that people like to a large number of
people is so insanely hard it boggles
the mind
um you know that's why I could say like
man there's a hell of a difference
between a company that has shift product
and one has not sure product uh it's a
game this is night and day
um and then even once you ship product
can you make the cost the value of the
output worth more than the cost of the
input which is again insanely difficult
especially with Hardware so
um but I think over time I think we cool
to do creative things and have like
eight arms and whatever
um and have different versions uh and
maybe you know there'll be some Hardware
like companies that are able to add
things to an optimist like maybe we've
you know added at a power port or
something like that or attach them you
can add you know add attachments to your
Optimist like you can add them to your
phone
um it could be a lot of cool things that
could be done over time and there could
be maybe an ecosystem of small companies
that or companies that make add-ons for
Optimus
so with that uh uh
just thank the team for their hard work
uh you guys are awesome and uh yeah
and uh thank
you and uh
thank you all for coming and for
everyone online thanks for tuning in
um and I think uh this will be one of
those great videos where you can like if
you you can fast forward to the bits
that you find most interesting but we
try to give you a tremendous amount of
detail uh literally so you can look at
the video at your leisure and you can
focus on the parts that you find
interesting and skip the other parts uh
so thank you all it's and we'll do this
try to do this every year and uh we
might do a part a monthly podcast even
um uh so uh but I think it'll be you
know uh great to sort of
bring you along for the ride and and
like show you uh what what cool things
are are happening and um yeah thank you
all right thanks
[Applause]
thank you